[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey here we go it's another saturday the
saturday after thanksgiving at least if
you're in the united states
hopefully how much weight did everyone
gain over the last couple days
i still got half a turkey at least and
then a whole other turkey that was
uncooked
it was a little cur they had a little
turkey there for like four bucks
yeah i said i'm not leaving without that
little boy i love turkey man
so i'm just going to cook another turkey
once this once once i got the bread
with this one yeah i got i got one third
of a breast left
and one yeah there's a lot of times a
leg a whole leg
yep then the back and a couple of wings
and then i'll
i'll strip that carcass down and i'll
cook that other one well we have a [ __ ]
ton of sides left got a [ __ ] ton of
all the potatoes are gone but we have
like tons of everything else yeah
yeah corn stuffing yeah mashed potato uh
corn stuffing sweet potatoes yeah um
cranberry stuff yeah homemade cranberry
and
like we have almost a whole brazilian
cream corn yeah we have almost the whole
pumpkin pie
yeah about half or a third of an apple
pie and a half or a third of a pecan pie
yeah we just
wake up eat thanksgiving we eat
thanksgiving three times a
that's okay it's good yeah
[Laughter]
shit's delicious i don't mind
but yeah so hi everybody it's saturday
once again
yeah everybody showed up big crowd there
big crowd in there
i feel like maybe we i don't know if we
get more people in when it's like gonna
be a true crime show
yeah maybe i don't know yeah but this
one uh
i've been wanting to do this one for a
while we actually talked a little bit
about
the hillside strangler case when we did
the show about the alphabet murders
because one of the guys who was one of
the hillsides they called the hillside
strangler but it's actually two guys
which i'm sure most you probably know
but one of the guys that was one of the
hillside stranglers
ken bianchi was also is also a suspect
in the alphabet murders
case which we mentioned back then um so
if you want to see the thing about the
alphabet murders we did a show about
that a while back because i mostly want
to concentrate on these particular
murders i don't know if ken bianchi did
those
did the alphabet murders maybe he did it
sounds
plausible but i don't know all the girls
are here all the girls
so got uh tila's in there
uh my boy xanada's in there deep maniacs
there
everybody's here bees nest
tammy everybody's here yeah and then
we've got
pushing 50 people in the chat which
that's huge for us this little bitty
show
yeah i look at some of these other shows
show that good yeah i look at some of
these other shows i get jealous i'm
looking they got like 5 000 people in
the [ __ ] chat don't be
jealous like 5 000. yeah nothing but
just [ __ ] super chats we would never
like who the hell
like we can't talk to people like the
same way when you have 5 000 people
malachi washington says where do you
guys take case requests anywhere
um you can recommend something in here
if you want to and i'll write it down
and put it
i have um i don't know if you're like
fairly new or something but i have like
a little topic boxes
so i have a topic box and i have a movie
retrospective box so if you have an idea
for
an old movie or a topic that you want us
to cover
then i'll write it down and i put it in
the one of the boxes and then i do a
poll
every week for patrons and they vote on
which one
they want us to do the upcoming week and
uh
this week hillside strangler won by a
very large margin
um so i was kind of glad about that
because i like i said i've been want to
do this case for a long time
because it's one of those cases of
serial killer teams that that aren't a
couple
you know what i mean because we've done
shows on those who every valentine's day
we do a killer couple show which is kind
of [ __ ] up but whatever that's how we
roll
um this is one of the few that was kind
of like two guys and they're actually
like family members they were cousins
they're not blood cousins because ken
bianchi was adopted
but um by his parents but they you know
were kind of like relatives
and they kind of so i don't know if like
they would have
done the same [ __ ] if they hadn't
started hanging out together
or if you know who knows um yeah so i
want to kind of talk they thought they
were gangsters too
well one of them did yeah yeah for sure
you thought he was in the mafia
yeah angelo buono or bono i've heard it
pronounced both ways it looks like it
would be blown out to me because it has
a u in it
but you know what do i know i'm not
italian um so
yeah so that's what we're going to be
talking about this evening is the
hillside
strangler case if you guys didn't know
there was there been several movies made
about these two lowlifes
but there was one that was made in 1989
and it was made for tv
and i found it on youtube and i watched
it yesterday
and it had [ __ ] billy zane
was played ken bianchi uh
dennis farina played angela buono
which you know he's been like tons of
things he was also like one of the
hosts for um unsolved mysteries like
after uh
robert stack died and [ __ ] uh
who was the other guy that was in it uh
[ __ ] i can't remember i was i wrote it
down like at the
at the end but yeah it was actually like
really good and it was um
it was based on kind of like the
definitive like hillside stranglers book
which i think was written by darcy
o'brien
uh and it kind of like followed that
pretty well but uh yeah pretty decent
movie it's on
youtube for free if you want to watch it
so i don't know
like i don't think we have any
particular shout outs this week we
didn't get any new patrons
which is sad um we oh no
we didn't get any cool any cool presents
in the mail or nothing like that
um if you are a patron please remember
to go vote in the polls for what you
want next week's movie and next week's
topic to be you have until tomorrow at
noon eastern standard time to vote
uh looks like there's a couple that are
like really close so your vote
could make all the difference so go do
that
also i think i mentioned it on last
week's show
but i redid one of my novels the five
poisons
um i did the print version and the
e-book version like i updated them
got a new cover fixed all the mistakes
everything
those are both available on amazon i
also did an audio book version
which should be online shortly because
like i said it usually takes two or
three weeks to go through
quality control so i'll let everybody
know when that is out
as well um and i think that's all also
we have a crazy pokey story
from last night yeah this is insane yeah
pookie ran up to the back uh door or
something in her mouth and i was like
is that a frog what is it it looked like
a really big frog it looked big
and it was kind of saw a little bit of
white and gray and i grabbed her and
[ __ ] put my hand in there to get what
it was
and it was a it was a flying squirrel it
bit me
yeah but i held it for a while it bit me
but it's not bad
and then it jumped on me and ran up and
it jumped off of my shoulder and hit the
side of the house
and ran up the side of the house and
just hung there from the side for a few
hours okay
yeah there's a southern flying squirrel
they're small i thought it was a baby
yeah we thought it was a baby squirrel
at first but then it flew
yeah about the size of a chipmunk
they're not very big
i had never i mean there is squirrels
all over this place but i had never seen
a flying squirrel in florida before yeah
they must be nocturnal
yeah maybe they are that's like that's
[ __ ] crazy so there could be little
squirrels flying around all night and we
didn't even know about it
they don't really fly they glide well i
know that yeah they don't really fly mr
pedantic
yeah it's more like a parachute squirrel
yeah they just have like little
arm flaps but yeah it's just
for pookie to like come up and be like
look what i got look she didn't hurt him
no um she had invited nape to the neck
i'm sure she probably would have
carried like a puppy she dropped it
though actually as soon as i
tried to grab it she dropped it and then
ran from it like there it is
just showing it to me look what i got
yeah yeah she didn't really seem to want
to tear it up she just wanted to go like
look at this isn't this neat
i've noticed that if it's cute and furry
she doesn't attack it
it's got to be ugly yeah she'll attack
that
whereas beijing doesn't give two [ __ ]
she'll just tear squirrel's head right
off
right but
you know i don't know pookie's still
probably
okay but bee's nest is asking me if
booby traps are
legal in florida no they're not no i
didn't think all booby traps
would be considered something like a
destructive device they'd come after you
for that
you can have perimeter warnings which
you can buy those if you know where to
find them
which is nothing but just a pull cord on
the end of a little
spring-loaded metal device on a spike
that you can put in the ground
and it hits a a shotgun primer and it
goes pop like that
you can strain those things up around
your perimeter someone can sneak up on
you at night
while you're camping now you take that
same perimeter
warning thing and you plug that in the
back of a [ __ ] pipe bomb and you got
something but i didn't say that
you did though you said that
right in public where everyone's gonna
hear you yeah yeah
yeah you probably should have thought
everything is filled everything
even in the army a lot of the [ __ ] that
we used for things like that
there was field improv involved with
that
like you know changing the fuses out
on grenades so there's no timer you know
like the
the fuse for a smoke grenade you can put
that inside of a [ __ ] high explosive
grenade you put that in an ammo box and
fill it up full of gasoline and soap
flakes or pieces of styrofoam
and and turn it into kind of like a
sticky napalm and it's called an eagle
fireball
and you pull on it boom it blows up it's
not something that we
actually did in a regular basis but it's
just something they make you aware of
there's a lot of cool [ __ ] you can do
it's always the field improvised stuff
it's always about triggers
and you have to understand how triggers
work which uh
i ain't gonna give you a class on on
[ __ ] field improvised munitions or
anything but
it's out there by the way thank you tim
and happy thanksgiving to you
as well um so yeah
somebody asked too if we had seen the
video of the florida man saving the
puppy
from the alligator yeah yeah i think
everybody
i couldn't really like i kind of saw it
out of the corner of my eye but i was
like i don't want to watch it it's like
too upsetting
even though the puppy like you know
spoiler alert the puppy's okay
but uh that's pretty hardcore he's like
hey you leave my puppy alone mr
alligator i'm gonna jump right into your
[ __ ] mouth again
that little puppy i don't blame that
dude though
i would do the same i'd wrestle an
alligator if pookie was in danger
no problem yeah that was a little
alligator you can wrestle a big
alligator
you can punch that out well the well
alligators have a weak point
in that you know they're if you you can
just hold their
jaw shut like with your hand you know
what i mean they don't have a lot of
like
power to spring it open like now
chomping down on you that's a different
story
um but if you but that's all you need is
like just put your hand around their
snout and they can't open their mouth
it's just uh you're really you're really
risking it if you're
getting in there and trying to manhandle
an alligator that's bigger than you
there are guys that can do it
but you have to know how to approach
them you got to come up from the back
got to grab them and hold their mouth
shut and then you need somebody else to
pull them on the tail and pull them out
with water and you kind of
twist tie their legs up behind them so
they can't go anywhere and
tape their mouth shut you know there's
ways to deal with them
i held a little i held a little bitty
alligator like who had his little mouth
tape shot at the alligator farm in st
augustine you know what i mean the baby
alligators are cute big ones
not so much big ones are actually pretty
scary
everybody's talking out into the world
stuff tila says i would wrestle one to
save my kitties too
yeah hey tila did you see those movies
there was a movie that you were going to
watch
which which one was it uh she saw a
heavy metal there was another one that i
i recommended
i forgot what it was she said she was oh
uh art of self-defense did you see it
you want to see art of self-defense and
you want to see bavarium that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] wild too
jesse eisenberg did them both they're
like art
school projects or well not really
they're like art films
but good man real good bavarian was like
uh
it was a sci-fi flick it was weird yeah
like twilight zone
yeah mixed with predator
the predator is not a predator predator
is more like a parasite
yeah yeah it's extra dimensional
parasites
yeah that was a good flick and we've
seen it probably like three or four
yeah we got it like considering that it
just came out not that long ago we've
seen it a whole bunch of times
oh and also i should say that we're
going to review it tomorrow so i don't
want to talk about it too much
but we did actually watch christmas
chronicles 2 which has dropped on
netflix in case you didn't know
with crustal and santa claus and also
goldie hawn as it as mrs claus
so we watched it the other night we'll
review that tomorrow she saw it dead and
buried it was a good movie
oh that's right yeah that's right we
talked about that saw a bunch of other
stuff like martyrs oh my god yeah that's
pretty much the word for that
um dead buried was creepy martyrs dead
very creepy dead and buried creeped me
out at like 12 or 13 years old when that
[ __ ] i saw that before the [ __ ]
mountain thing that was a [ __ ] creepy
ass mood
i gotta see it again it's on uh shutter
right there is it
yeah danada says you guys seem stoned
today i wish nah just kind of
kind of slow we're slow we're not drunk
enough to
well wait a minute have you really drunk
that much already yeah well i didn't put
very much orange juice in this one was
pretty strong
oh i'm trying to jump start the action
like i said you're going to be running
around naked
just start the action we just get all
kinds of subscribers
[Laughter]
well it could be either way we could get
a bunch of subscribers or we could
get a bunch of unsubscribes like yep i'm
out
running around all naked and stuff but
says varian was about parenting and an
adult
no not really it was kind of kinda that
was only the half of the thing
it was go back and watch it again
it had a lot to do with the [ __ ] an
extra dimensional parasite similar to
the cuckoo bird it forces you to raise
this child
it showed in the book what was happening
you got to freeze frame it
of what it the book that it brought back
that [ __ ] was not happening in this
dimension
it was happening in a yeah parallel
dimension but he meant that it's a
it's it was like a metaphorical movie
about it could be that too
it is yeah but that particular parasite
accelerated all that [ __ ] in about what
an 18-month period
yeah didn't it was something like
actually i don't even think it was that
long yeah it was lit
but about a year it was full-grown and
it had [ __ ] eaten you up
and the parents i think died i think it
was feeding off of them somehow
on an extra dimensional level sucking
their souls or something
because they started then they started
to [ __ ] wither up and remember
you could when they died you could just
take them and roll them up like they
were made out of paper
yeah it's like crazy it wasn't happening
in this dimension
yeah because remember it ran underneath
the curve and she went through a couple
other dimensions and there were other
people raising those things it was like
a nest of them
like a wasp nest yeah she also said uh
run on hulu which is actually on my list
to review for the matinee show because
i've heard a lot of people talking about
how good that was so um i have hulu so
i'm probably gonna watch that the next
couple days i might maybe i'll watch it
tomorrow night we can review it monday
because like i said tomorrow we'll
probably review the christmas chronicles
sequel
because we just watched that the other
night i think we watched that
on the night before thanksgiving maybe
right yeah uh yeah that was probably it
was pretty good flick
all right so are you ready to start
talking about the hillside strangler
yeah yeah
okay uh dj maniac says i added peeping
tom to my q on 2b but i haven't had a
chance to watch it yet okay it's well
it's good it's like it's a really good
important
film uh and everyone should see it
uh especially if you're into psycho and
stuff like that if you're into like
horror film
history okay zachary what did i miss not
much uh you missed the crazy pookie
story which is probably the best part
of her catching a flag squirrel yeah
the squirrel was okay right i mean the
squirrel seemed
the squirrel was okay this the squirrel
seemed okay she didn't she didn't hurt
it no
that's just like really funny she just
wanted to come up on the porch and be
like hey check it out
i'm a master hunter i caught a flying
squirrel
but yeah so let's talk about the
hillside strangler case you ready
yeah all right i can't believe you drank
that much already
oh my goodness well it was only up to
here i'm only halfway through it
oh okay all right it's a little more
concentrated this one i'll believe
you're trying to get some alcohol into
the system kind of jump started
just shocked to the system wow look at
all that yeah
i'm just i got booze and i just had a
little piece of apple pie
i'm feeling small too man my hormones
aren't doing good
i'm coming off of tom's daily hormone
report
oh my hormones oh my sciatica oh my
coming off all that [ __ ] for about a
week it's not trying to go back to
normal
i'm feeling [ __ ] small and weak small
weak and pitiful i feel i feel i feel
metrosexual
really yeah i feel metrosexual i don't
know what it is
i'm not sure what to do with that
information i don't know what it is i
just don't feel i don't
we're gonna get it right yes we're gonna
get it right eventually
tim said have you done anything on the
dardeen family martyrs i think i talked
about that on
we did a show like a long time ago it
was probably two years ago
where we talked about um it was one of
our special edition shows i think shawna
and eric were here
and uh we did like top 10 like family
massacres or something i don't even know
if we did 10 of them because i think it
was taking so long that we said [ __ ] it
we're just doing four or whatever
but i think that we did talk about the
dardeen family on that one if i'm
remembering it correctly but yeah that
was uh pretty [ __ ] up
all right so let's talk about the
hillside strangling
this [ __ ] here it's [ __ ] what are you
okay look at
he's always like fidgeting it's in the
middle it's in the way okay
then i'm over here zach says tom i felt
gay and heavily pregnant
and in need of a bra because of pandemic
eating who said this
zach he did easy he messaged me earlier
on facebook
it said that he felt like he was looking
for a bra
i was showing that i was shocked i was
showing zack some [ __ ]
judas priest videos back when [ __ ]
rob halford was in his prime back when
he was in full [ __ ] daddy mode
and and and and i that's what that's
what that's what did that to you zach
he increased all that gaystrigin
yeah it caused you to grow breasts and
made him pregnant made you pregnant too
that's through the internet that's what
[ __ ] rob halfer was a warrior gay man
you had to [ __ ] watch out for that
[ __ ] if he
passed too close behind you he'd
impregnate a man in a heartbeat
like something damn alien movie
didn't know what could happen did you
now you know
well then you guys see that movie night
of the blood beast that was on mystery
science theater
and it was in fact on the turkey day
marathon which i sat there and watched
the entire [ __ ] 12 hours of because
that's how i do
um but yeah night of the blood beast was
about and that came out in the [ __ ]
50s
that was about a guy he was like an
astronaut and then he comes back to
earth and he had been impregnated by an
alien yeah
he had like a bunch of little shrimp in
his stomach
what they were shrimp that's [ __ ]
hilarious i'm telling you they were
shrimp dude yeah
it was they looked like underneath the
microscope they did
little sperms up in there being that
yeah he's like oh my god i'm gonna give
birth to like a dozen scampi
[Laughter]
i was like that was pretty crazy for the
50s like a man getting impregnated by an
alien yeah
so of course like on mst they had a
[ __ ] field day with that like all the
[ __ ] about like
what happened between this man at the
same time
like how he got impregnated because they
didn't go that much into it in the movie
jesus says i'm not gay with my boyfriend
tina's talking about me being
metrosexual we need to get my fashion
game on
i got to go off to armani and stuff yeah
yeah there you go you need like a real
sharp suit
yeah maybe get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
tailored like doctor who
yeah there you go the little [ __ ]
skinny skinny leg [ __ ] skinny pants
skinny pants suit yeah get this get that
[ __ ] oh plaid
yeah what uh sonder says wasn't arnold
pregnant too in a movie yeah
junior yeah to alex said junior yeah
that was a dumbass movie
i never saw it it was dumb
[Laughter]
that was towards the end of arnold you
didn't want to see arnold schwarzenegger
pregnant
arnold movies started to suck after a
while i lost you know what i mean
90s i feel like we should watch it just
so
just so i can see your reaction to it i
i want to see i want to see what you're
feeling is
seeing arnold schwarzenegger pregnant
and i'm an arnold fan
i like arnold i like arnold as a man
i think especially well he's still he's
a man in this movie he's just a pregnant
and talking about just as a dude
especially back when he was in
his in the golden era of the 70s and the
80s and he's [ __ ] working out and
competing and stuff he was i thought he
was cooler back then
um now by the 90s and the 2000s started
to roll around
you know politics kind of [ __ ] up
arnold i
kind of [ __ ] arnold up i think you
know what i mean he came back kind of
i don't know came back different
but i think they got dirt on him or
something he didn't come back
he's not like the arnold that i grew up
with the arnold i grew up with is funny
he's a lot funnier and and he would he
didn't care about
he he could be caustic you know he could
be a dick because
you just you listen to all listen to
leroy colbert
or colbert calls himself colbert too
he's old bodybuilder
who came up with grew up without our
with arnold but i didn't really he
didn't grow up with
he came up with arnold through the 70s
and he was this uh he was like the first
black
dude to be on the cover of uh one of the
muscle magazines
uh joe weeder's magazine leroy
and leroy would tell you all about
arnold all right and [ __ ]
what arnold used to be like arnold was
stuck up he was a dick
but he was funny yeah i've heard that
yeah and he was going on about what
he was going to conquer hollywood and he
was going to be rich and famous
and that and that you know the [ __ ]
leroy's [ __ ] thought he was [ __ ]
crazy
that dude turned out to everything he
said turned out to be true though
that he talking hollywood ended up being
the governor of california the thing
about it though is that lots of people
talk like that
and 99 of them don't do that
yeah arnold schwarzenegger was a
different [ __ ] story he was a
austrian
tank soldier he was a tanker when he was
in the austrian army and he was a
[ __ ] bodybuilder and he'd [ __ ]
run from the [ __ ] austrian army to
just to do a do a [ __ ]
a quick [ __ ] uh bodybuilding show and
then you go back in you know what i mean
he was kind of a troublemaker but
everybody liked him you know and uh
he just uh he was just a character they
said he was a [ __ ]
a real had a real powerful
magnetic personality they said that when
he was around you you couldn't you
couldn't really help yourself
you kind of would just kind of go along
with what he wanted to do and [ __ ]
you know
he was just part of his personality that
he was extremely
charming uh what's the word i'm looking
for charismatic
he was extremely charismatic and um
dude [ __ ] ended up [ __ ] dude who
could [ __ ] sounded like [ __ ]
back in the day okay ended up conquering
hollywood
and becoming the governor of california
it was very unlikely that could only
happen through [ __ ] nietzschean will
it willpower and and talent he was a
talented guy
but uh his last greatest movie was
i think it was called was the one about
the cloning i think it was called
the sixth the sixth day yes
well did maggie come out before that
maggie no maggie came out after maggie
was good too but that just happened
he he did a very good performance in
terms of terms of acting in maggie
it's a zombie flick yeah but it's not a
big budget action flick
i really liked maggie actually maggie
was good but maggie was like an art
flick
it was it was a art flick he was trying
to show up
sly that he could actually act because
stallone
and his other buddy who's [ __ ]
playing yeah there's a big rivalry big
[ __ ] doofer man lauren come on um
carl weather carl yeah
[Laughter]
carl would drive the [ __ ] out of arnold
about him not being able to act
all right and that's why
really arnold's best performance was in
predator one
predator and that's because carl was
[ __ ] just giving him he's riding his
ass
[ __ ] driving him all right and that
actually
brought the best out of arnold i think
that's arnold's best best
performance really in terms of overall
overall it's his best performance um now
in terms of just pure acting i'd say
maggie
yeah but i was surprised by how good he
was yeah he was very good in that
but as far as like the the last greatest
arnold schwarzenegger style [ __ ]
action flick that was the sixth day
that was a pretty good movie i liked
today i liked maggie better though but
yeah it was it was along the line of
you know [ __ ] um you know total
recall
it was a movie kind of like that i liked
it because that's the thing about sly
because even though sylvester stallone
was
a bodybuilder too he was also not only
like a really good actor but he was also
a writer like he wrote screenplays and
stuff like that so he was like a lot
so he was like a double like triple you
have to understand something
you have to understand son
[Laughter]
sly dude we're like half an hour
sly was an artist before he was a
bodybuilder
he got into that scene and they [ __ ]
you know what i mean and then he became
a bodybuilder after he was already an
artist but
out of all the dudes that were talking
about those 80s action [ __ ] stars
styvester stallone was the most
artistically
gifted one he was he was [ __ ] great
he was very great
yeah um thank you tila thanks tila
what's she saying what's she saying
appreciate you lovely to keep on rocking
in the free world thank you babe
keep on rocking in the free world oh man
don't get me singing again
no sly and sly
is strong to this day he still makes
great movies that other people won't
make
that last [ __ ] rambo was good uh
[ __ ] all the expendable [ __ ] was good
he is a very artistic artistically
talented
guy and he's got good-looking daughters
[Laughter]
which is very important celeste sistine
yes i felt like sistine chapel yes
justine she's cute as [ __ ]
and um he's you know for being an old
dude he's still in [ __ ] real good
shape real good shape
yeah he he's going when he dies he's
going to die strong you're not going to
die weak
i wish i could die like that you want to
die strong you don't want to die weak
well yeah yeah i'm talking about and um
stallone was in a porno yeah he was he
was italian
yeah which is funny because angelo buono
one of the hillside stranglers was also
known as the italian stallion
slides the [ __ ] slides the [ __ ] he um he
made it
he seemed like a cool dude he made yeah
very cool uh he he made some bad movies
but
he's a stopper my mom will shoot yeah he
made some bad moves
but the ones that he had the most to do
with
were good yeah if they let him like rush
it or you know i would say
develop the character my favorite one
with him have been demolition man
a lot of people [ __ ] panned i love
demolition man
all right a lot of people panned uh
judge dredd but i liked
judge dredd saw it recently on blu-ray
it was [ __ ] great it's better today
than it was back then
although i will say that the remake that
they did that was just called dread was
actually was was actually very very good
real good i was surprised by how awesome
that movie was i wasn't expecting it all
the expendables are masterpieces of what
they are
um the rambos were all good that last
rambo was pretty good
yeah rambo the fight continues is
probably the best rambo movie
though was that the one where he just
like shot everybody everybody up yeah
he's down in myanmar
yeah that's my favorite one i found that
one really entertaining even though
because it was just like so much gore
even though sly's face is kind of [ __ ]
up from all that gh he was taking
it is but he fixed it he fixed it yeah
like i said it's just
it just like was a bunch of bad guys
getting their heads blown off i'm just
kind
all the rockies they were [ __ ] all
all good they were all good yeah
and [ __ ] call was in them too that
was when call was [ __ ] great
call is always great man we saw a call
on [ __ ] mandalorian a couple days
back he directed and starred in that
[ __ ] second to the last one
carl's [ __ ] going he i wasn't aware
of this but somebody or i read it
somewhere
when i was reading about the mandalorian
carl weathers directed some
episodes of [ __ ] silk stockings back
in the days
do you remember
[Laughter]
so he's directed other things too carl
carl was kind of like um
he was he was a guy who was a lot like
sylvester stallone yeah you know i mean
it's another real [ __ ] built dude who
was actually talented he could act he
could write he could direct
a couple people have also recommended
copland have you seen that
man everybody's telling me to see it you
shouldn't see it i saw it in the theater
when it came out
and it's it's really really good i think
that was kind of the first i mean yes he
got taken seriously for rocky and
everything but i think cop land was like
the first movie that everybody's like
hey this dude can like really [ __ ]
act holy crap
yeah you know what i mean it was kind of
like that kind of moment when did that
come out 90s i want to say it was early
90s yeah yeah
yeah 90s something gained a bunch of
weight because i remember seeing it in
the theater
me and my friend wasn't on the theater
who was the guy that was um
[ __ ] he was in the expendables too he
was in expendables also he was in um
idiocracy
he's that [ __ ] um when he was in high
school he was a football player he's a
black dude
um he's [ __ ] real he's big dude
[ __ ] real [ __ ] cool what's his
name
you guys know what i'm talking about i
can't remember and he was in the
expendables he's not going to be in the
net
in the upcoming expendables they're
making another one
yeah they're going to make another one i
think lee priest is going to be in it is
chuck norris going to be in it
no no i wish when chuck gets in that
[ __ ] they want to make it
[ __ ] pg because that dude won't cuz
won't be in a movie that has cussing
yeah they probably won't even
they're like get out of here you're no
fun you guys know who i'm talking about
[ __ ] it's on the tip of my tongue it's a
[ __ ]
black guy he's kind of like a
bodybuilder terry crews terry crews
terry crews man
thank you louis my head injury i'm
basically really hard fishing i'm
drinking it's hard for you to remember
new
[ __ ] terry's another one man that
[ __ ] was it's a lot more
talented than people give him credit for
and terry had a
a lot terry's [ __ ] he's a brave dude
he came out about
sexual abuse and [ __ ] that was happening
in hollywood you realize that
yeah man tried to [ __ ] take advantage
of him yeah couldn't resist that bbc
guess not gonna come up there and just
look at it and he's like man hey
i'm just here to work all right
you know what i mean can you you can't
use me as your stallion take that
yeah he came out behind that i got a lot
of respect for him
but uh yeah terry crews i need to see
some terry crews i feel like
dudes that are bodybuilders and also
actors
they get the same kind of [ __ ] as
perhaps
well or a big titty woman or a woman
who's like exceptionally beautiful
or like blonde or something it's like oh
they can't possibly have any substance
like
beyond that i feel like that's kind of
fallen by the wayside a little bit but i
do feel like that's kind of like the
male
equivalent of like the hot chick with
big boobs like how she must be stupid
well there's a lot of guys that right
now on on youtube right now making
in the fitness game that back in the day
you just would have seen him in a
magazine
maybe an action flick but now they got
their own [ __ ] accounts you know what
i mean and they're making big money you
know like greg doucette
and you got [ __ ] um other dudes like
him
and they're now [ __ ] online media
personalities so people can now see what
they're like back in the day like they
had steve reeves and like mickey
hargitay and up that were in like
hercules movies and [ __ ]
that's kind of what they did back then
and then they got that dude from
beastmode which is his name chris
jones i think chris jones for beast mode
he's a
[ __ ] uh he's got his own gym and
everything
he's got there's a big fight going on
between him and doucet
because the bigger and prettier
[ __ ] is gonna get the more of a
[ __ ] he's gonna get yeah [ __ ] are
gonna start [ __ ] fighting each other
and talking [ __ ] to each other i [ __ ]
love it though
it is [ __ ] funny they're like the
biggest [ __ ] it is [ __ ] funny
seriously
men are the biggest [ __ ] ever look
you guys know that i made this [ __ ]
strong
all right just so he's already starting
all right like i said we're like we
we've only been going for like half an
hour 40 minutes and he's already like
this i haven't even started talking
about the case yet this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
about men not being a [ __ ] no you
don't understand when i was in the army
this goes back to [ __ ] rangers and
special forces the biggest [ __ ] you
could ever [ __ ] imagine
imagine a [ __ ] tough man composition
or excuse me
a tough man competition that is kind of
like
the miss america pageant yeah imagine it
like that [ __ ] all happened or never
saying it's always been my experience
this is why i always kind of get annoyed
like when dudes are like oh man women
are such [ __ ] i'm like
have you hung out with you guys before
because
yeah in my experience like dudes are way
bigger [ __ ] than women are
generally during the time i was in the
army the [ __ ] army was
one big tough man competition
between a bunch of [ __ ] miss america
[ __ ]
that's what it was it was constant ego
warfare
yeah because i do feel like you know yes
women can be competitive with one
another but i do feel like
men are like way more competitive with
one another than women are
way more competitive much worse i mean
you know
i definitely feel like that's the case i
mean you know
you know yeah you're right you're gonna
live through this go ahead i gotta put a
scroll back and see what everybody's
holy [ __ ] man it's like i haven't
got 65. i haven't got to the hour point
i've even really started talking about
the case i just gave like a general
rundown and like a recommendation to go
watch the [ __ ] move
i could not believe this [ __ ] tv
movie there's been more than one there's
been like several there's one that came
out in 2001 there's one that came out in
2004
i think this one came out in 2006. um
but this one in particular i couldn't
believe like it was [ __ ] star-studded
man and it was actually really good i
cannot
um the the movie about the um the
hillside strangler
oh yeah yeah hold on one second louis
hernandez
uh yeah man um
the the creed movies were very good i
got them both they were yeah i liked it
yeah and that's another stallone
production
stallone knows how to [ __ ] get to
take those testosterone-laden [ __ ]
stories and dudes and [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] to where you can
you can kind of like have feelings for
the people
he's very those kind of movies are the
only movies that dudes are allowed to
watch and they can cry
and no one will call them a [ __ ] yeah
i'm just saying that's like because
dudes are allowed to cry at certain
movies
but you know what i mean and not be
called like womany or whatever
yeah um mango says is the christmas
chronicles sequel come on yet yes it is
it's there they added it wednesday yeah
for the day before thanksgiving they
added it christmas chronicles 2 is good
we'll probably review it tomorrow on
that day is it as good as christmas
chronicles one
no not really but christmas chronicles
one was a christmas movie that was hard
to top
this one is not really a christmas movie
this one is a [ __ ] north pole movie
it is in the sense that santa's in it
and [ __ ] but it's less christmas focused
as more like
north pole and like right and and
cats yeah it's more like norse
pagan yeah they've they've opened the
mythology they've opened up the scope
this scope of the movie [ __ ] um
crusoe did did a great job in it well
obviously yeah did a great job in it
goldie's in it a lot she's [ __ ] she
did it i like that they expanded her
role yeah
like in this a lot because she's cute as
a button um
they got um they kind of made the story
so you have
the the girl from the first movie she's
a few years older and then she's got
like her possible future step brother
with her who's this little black kid
and there at the north pole which i i
liked how they did that story they're
trying to um
they made sure that they're trying to
[ __ ] get it so
christmas is for everybody it's an
american slash european
uh thing and they start getting real
germanic and real norse with it
but they got a black kid in the in the
middle of the story which
that's good because that kind of in it's
introducing or making acceptable
that culture to the [ __ ] mainstream
of america or the broader
audience you know which i like that i
thought that was a good idea
well i like that they went with a lot of
like kind of pagan
mythology in it a little bit we're still
keeping the christianity [ __ ] too but
it's like so kind of make everybody
happy type of thing
it has to do with [ __ ] recapturing
the star of bethlehem and this and that
but also rule cat yellow nickel
that kind of stuff is all i liked it i
thought it was good and you know
tammy's saying how hilarious terry cruz
terry crews
did a fantastic job on one of my most
favorite movies called idiocracy
yeah everybody's seen it yeah not
everybody's seen it well i feel like
pretty much
[ __ ] say that at this point president
camacho and that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious man
and and you can learn a lot from the
movie idiocracy because it is a true
story
but uh let me get back idiocracy is a
[ __ ] true story
and another [ __ ] what i love is i
love office spaces but he's not in that
office you always say it wrong yeah
everyone says
[Laughter]
i mean office space was like one of the
most
memeable i still see memes of that dudes
being like yeah i'm gonna need you to
come in
yeah yeah that was there was like a
whole meme series of that dude
that era was the corporate world when i
got out of the army and [ __ ] ended up
working for the companies that i worked
with that was the one well yeah a lot of
people
hated that yeah i did too so a lot of
people could relate to that [ __ ] because
it's like
so glad that that world is basically
gone at least for me
it makes me so happy that i don't have
to let go on office every day because i
hated that
and i hate i hated meetings i hated all
that kind of [ __ ] i'm just like why do
we have to do this what's the point of
this i don't understand
yeah but yeah how awesome terry cruz i'm
a big fan of terry crews even though i'm
like i forget his name
[Laughter]
you forget him you forgive me you forget
my name sometimes
i don't think you've ever forgotten my
name no and i've called you stephanie
that's which is my ex's name no that was
my xxx
i was going to say i was like your
ex-wife's name is tiffany
stephanie i saw this [ __ ] yeah one
time you called me by your ex-wife all
those
super high falutin white girl names i
dated him
[Laughter]
he had one of each i had one yeah i
didn't have a buffy but that's i was
just gonna say that like
how about buffy karen
yeah no no karen's [ __ ] here i don't
even know any karen's i mean i know some
karen's
no karen's no becky's one of my best
friends in high school was becky but
she's not like
a becky like louie says [ __ ] tom's
getting faded already it's gonna be a
great show yeah
say we're not even an hour and and he's
already turbocharging this [ __ ]
he's already [ __ ] oh my god and i
prepared so hard for this [ __ ] show
too
yeah i watched i watched like three or
four documentaries about these two
[ __ ] i watched one of the two made
for tv movies
i read two books about this [ __ ] case
like on [ __ ]
my uh kindle unlimited and i read like
all the [ __ ] on murderpedia and all that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah tina said and then people are
agreeing saying that yeah office space
her one of her favorite ones
tila i'm telling you even though you're
a newcomer to this show
you're going to love art of self-defense
you're going to love artists
self-defense
and vivarium it's got the pretty much
the same cast go check that [ __ ] out you
will [ __ ] love it even though they're
not
comedies but it
you'll see when you get there see art of
self-defense i keep telling you you
should probably watch the social network
i gotta see that one where jesse
eisenberg plays mark zuckerberg they
found her a favorite
it's about the founding of facebook i
saw that in the theater as well yeah
seriously
even though i don't like that lizard
looking [ __ ] that's a damn
cyborg
well he's got to be a cyborg call david
icky or ike or whatever that dude's name
is he's a lizard he's a [ __ ] lizard
man
he does not you see his eyes look at his
eyes i don't
look at him it's like something out of
jaws lifeless eyes like a dog like a dog
like a doll's eye
all right quint
[Laughter]
his eyes are like a shark like a doll's
eye
lifeless eyes i don't like that dude
no man if i saw zuckerberg in person i'd
[ __ ] beat his ass there's something
unnatural about that dude well they
actually the social network
i'm scared of that dude nah i look at
that i'm scared of barking i'm scared of
that dude there's something about that
dude that's an alien
suit you gotta go it's like something no
social network is good because it kind
of portrays him
as like kind of a douche you know what i
mean definitely which i guess he kind of
is definitely but there's
something wrong i you know me for
[ __ ]
a decade at least huh yes about a decade
yeah
you know my [ __ ] senses over the time
you've been in the club i've got no
[ __ ] weird feelings about people and
[ __ ] right there right
and even though you don't agree with a
lot of the [ __ ] that i say
i've had a pretty good track record
haven't i about people
there's some [ __ ] about people i can
[ __ ] sense it's that [ __ ]
vibe it's that [ __ ] undertone it's a
very primal
instinctive reaction i have and
sometimes i fight it
i fight it and i try to use reason and
logic to talk myself out of my gut
reaction
all right but every time i do i [ __ ]
myself up i should just go with my gut
reaction
i look at mark zuckerberg and i'm going
that dude's [ __ ] there's something
wrong there
that's a bad dude he doesn't know he's
like a
like i said a lifeless eye like a doll
there's something wrong with that dude
now you're making me want to watch jaws
again
yeah i think he's a
i think he's a cyborg i think he's been
doing so wouldn't that be something
i think he's done some experimental [ __ ]
to himself
all i know is she's like
i think he's i think he's put something
in his [ __ ] head and i think he's got
fire brock
[ __ ] cables and [ __ ] going
his it's like he's seeing a heads-up
display in his eyes while he's talking
to you
he's like one of the cyborgs from
westworld that's what you're saying i
think he's accessing the internet ways
while you're talking to him
i think he's got a [ __ ] display i'm
just telling him
just telling him he's got money he's
done some kind of modifications to
himself
i've seen video of people talking to him
and it's either lsd
bad lsd or it could be that or he's
decided he could just be
on [ __ ] drugs all the time could be
could be because i feel like you're
something's wrong with him did we do i
don't think we did a whole show about
the lizard people but we were talking
about that type of thing
and one of the things that these crazy
people that think that
like all these people are lizard people
are in the illuminati or whatever the
[ __ ]
um one of the things that they bring out
is like evidence is that they're like
look at this video of eminem
like looking all spaced out for
something i'm like dude he's high as
[ __ ] yeah
you like not know what that looks like
or he's not a [ __ ] alien he's just
high as [ __ ]
he's high as balls right there i don't
understand yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah so uh you are you are right
yeah i'm fine i'm reading the reading
reading comments see what everybody's
saying can i talk about the case now go
ahead
all right so today finally
now that we're almost an hour in and tom
is probably already [ __ ] up yeah
they're [ __ ] going
santa the same time's gone yeah i'm not
gone i'm right here bro he's gonna like
how funny would it be like at the end of
the show because i know at the end of
the show sometimes like i can't remember
that of the show like i've always edited
it which is good but it's like he just
like fell sideways off the chair that
would be super funny
yeah hey there's this is nothing that a
piece of pie can't fade
can't can't fix are you gonna eat some
pie i might eat some pie
yeah i didn't realize that that somebody
had opened the pumpkin pie or i would
have i had apple pie earlier because i
figured well we
oh okay yeah i thought maybe because i i
didn't want to because the pumpkin pie
was like
virgin and hadn't been opened yet yeah i
thought we were
working our way through the pecan pie
and the apple pie before we got into the
porcupine
that pumpkin pie got a hold of me it was
calling me
so i'm gonna have to well i had apple
pie today so i'm gonna wait till i can't
have two pieces of pile just sitting
here talking to you is making me [ __ ]
think about that damn pecan pie though
no he's thinking about
that you know what i had a piece of that
it's good but pecan pie is really good
but you only need like a really
small piece because it is super sweet
you can't eat much of it you really
can't
it's delicious but it's like really
really sweet
like overwhelmingly sweet okay let's
start the show are you sure
yeah yeah hopefully i'll be able to
maintain
okay let's see how you do okay go ahead
okay we gotta talk about these two
[ __ ] douche bags here let's talk
about these things
one of the one of these douche bags is
still alive yeah which i didn't realize
i thought they were both dead one of
them is dead but uh
i've seen many programs about these two
guys man there's a lot of they did a
biography about them
there's been like a couple of british
documentaries about them like i said
there's been a whole bunch of like made
for tv movies direct-to-deep
dvd movies like [ __ ] like that about
these two idiots well just because like
i said
it's very rare i mean serial killers in
general are very rare
so when you find some that are working
as a team
that's like even more unusual and i
think the thing about these two guys is
that
even though they always kind of say in
serial killer pairs particularly
like when they're couples and stuff like
that because we've talked about that a
lot on some of our valentine's day shows
they always kind of feel like oh well
one's like the dominant one and it's
kind of like dragging the other one
along had they not
met you know maybe this one wouldn't be
a killer i don't know about these two
i'm not really sure
i feel like angelo buono being
much older because he was like 20 years
older than his nephew
or his cousin rather um that maybe he
was the ringleader but i don't know
because the thing about it is that when
angelo buono
i mean they killed a bunch of women
together and then like angelo bono was
like okay well we need to stop because
like there's too much heat on us or
whatever
and then it's significant that ken
bianchi was the one who went on to kill
people by himself
and got caught spoiler alert um
so i'm not sure like i don't know if
either of these two dudes like angelo
bono was
in prison like was in and out of prison
for other things
but not murder um before him and ken got
together
so would he have killed somebody if he
hadn't met ken
maybe um but i don't know it's just it
was a weird like dynamic between the two
of them
because i feel like one of them
wasn't necessarily dominant over the
other maybe angela was but it's hard to
say
like i've seen psychiatrists say like
maybe ken was the dominant one maybe
angela was the dominant one it's like
there's no way i know and what
fourth jordan down [ __ ] called it man
holy nichian act of will will enable tom
to resist the pecan pie
dude i'm sitting here thinking about
that pecan pie that's what he's been
thinking about the whole time
that's [ __ ] picaro pie's call of duty
with whipped cream man
[ __ ] right yeah i just had like a
little sliver of apple pie earlier
but uh well you can go get some pie if
you want just don't you don't chew with
your mouth i gotta make another
drink too and uh i was gonna have you
make me another one but it's
i still got like i still got like a
third left so i probably won't
all right so um so yeah so this is two
guys they're cousins like i said there
was a there was a large gap in age
um it's weird because it's usually
called the hillside strangler case
that's what the media dubbed it at the
time
because i guess the media when this [ __ ]
first started happening assumed
as you would that it was just one guy
like a serial killer
um but cops were pretty sure
from i think even the second or third
murder in the series
that this was probably two dudes um but
they didn't really let that slip
until later on so it just happened that
the media dubbed this person the
hillside strangler
even though later they ended up knowing
that it was two guys
that's usually what the case is called
so uh this occurred in a fairly
short time uh in california serial
killer capital of the world at least at
this time period
uh from late 1977 to early 1978.
they killed the two of them together
killed 10 women
aged between 12 and 28 years old
and then ken would go on to kill two
more by himself later on which is what
ended up getting him caught
um so you know so like i said this was a
very brief
time period so let's talk about
the first victim so the first victim
that they know of and like i said
this is the first victim so nobody knew
that there was a serial killer or
anything like that
and a lot of attention didn't get
placed on this case until later because
the first victim
actually the first couple of victims
were uh
sex workers or runaways or something of
that nature
and this was los angeles so
it was kind of like oh another
sex worker got killed oh another runaway
got killed it wasn't
you know what i mean it's kind of a
thing where it's a high risk
lifestyle you know a lot of murders
happened in los angeles this time period
so nobody like really thought there was
a serial killer going on time look at
you it's your [ __ ]
cop
[Laughter]
look at that
[Laughter]
beezness said reptilians gave me crabs
sure no that was those hookers down in
tj
maybe one thing or the other thing
that's a witch whichever
look at you eating the pie hell yeah
yeah
yeah oracle said nobody respectable got
killed at first i know and that's sad
and we've talked about that like
before i do feel like i'm not saying
that they don't take it as seriously or
they don't try to solve it it's just
kind of like
well [ __ ] happens like nobody really
thought that this was gonna like bloom
into anything else
so the first victim was a young woman
named yolanda washington she was 19
years old and uh she was a sex worker
now her body was found near the forest
lawn
cemetery uh near los angeles
on october 18 1977
now there wasn't a lot of trauma to the
body
but it appeared that the body had been
washed
and they found like some kind of faint
like ligature marks like around her
ankles and wrists and
uh neck so they assumed that she had
been tied up and
strangled um she had also been raped
a couple days later november 1st
1977 um police go to this
uh neighborhood called la crescenta uh
in los angeles and they found the body
of a teenage girl um as far as i know
all the bodies were found naked like
i've seen some of the crime scene photos
that are
pretty horrifying especially one of the
ones that they just kind of like left on
a hill like
overlooking the city you know what i
mean so there's like the shots from the
helicopter it's just like this
dead naked lady like laying there it's
like pretty [ __ ] up
so they find this girl and she's kind of
like
laying on the side of the road like face
up like
next to a parkway in a residential area
now i guess somebody that lived in the
area like
found her body because it was laying
right there it wasn't hidden or anything
and um this the guy that found her was
like afraid that the neighborhood kids
would like see her on their way to
school so he put like a tarp over her
or whatever and that like that family
ended up moving away later on because
that was just like so [ __ ] up so
this body also um you know didn't have a
lot of trauma to it but there was some
bruises that indicated that she had been
strangled
um they think probably this girl
as most of the other ones had been
killed elsewhere
and just dumped probably out of a car
now
later they identified this girl as a
girl named judy miller i think that the
cops
they didn't they had a sketch they made
a sketch of her and they kind of
released it to the media and there
wasn't really any
nobody like identified her but then they
took the sketch down to like the seedy
part of town where like all the hookers
and stuff hung out and
a bunch of people identified they said
oh that's judy um
so it was this girl she was 15 she had
like just turned 15 and she was a
runaway
and i guess had turned to prostitution
to get money
and that's who this ended up being
so she was the second victim
now five days after that and like i said
this is a very very this is like a
killing spree man this was like i think
it was just only four months with like
these 10 victims
so november 6 1977 they found
another naked dead body
this was found near the chevy chase
country club
this woman had also been strangled and
she was later
identified as a 21 year old named lissa
caston
now she was not a sex worker as far as
anyone could determine
she was actually a waitress she worked
like at a health food
restaurant or something like that i
can't remember what the name of it was i
saw it somewhere
um so she had actually last been seen
leaving work like the night before her
body was found and
she also had a job like working in her
dad's construction
business and was a ballet student um
so yeah so this was kind of the first
one the first victim that wasn't
straight up a sex worker and again
the fact that the cops from very very
early on
knew that they were probably dealing
with
two killers it was just because in the
locations like where a lot of the bodies
were found
they were usually like on i mean they
call them the hillside stranglers
because
they usually left the bodies like on a
hillside or
up in and around los angeles and some of
some of where the bodies were placed
it would have been very difficult for
one person
to have left the bodies where they were
found because sometimes it was like a
big guard rail
or it would have been too hard because
there were no drag marks there were
nothing like that
so it would have been hard for like one
person to just like lift this
body up and like put it over a guardrail
or whatever like the places they were
found so they assumed
that this that whoever had killed this
girl had helped
now the next couple victims were
were little girls uh this was two
little girls dolores cepeda who was 12
and sonya johnson who was 14. now these
two girls
um had gotten on their school bus this
was on november 13th
1977. um and they got on they were on
the bus they rode the bus they got off
the bus
and then somebody saw them getting off
the school bus
and walking up to a car that had two men
in it
now the following day uh or actually six
days later it was almost a week later i
believe
there was a little boy who was um
cleaning up like garbage from like a
hillside right near dodger stadium
and he was the one that found the bodies
that was on november 20th 1977
um and both the girls had been raped and
strangled now so the same day
that they found these two girls bodies
in another part of los angeles
they found like some people hiking found
another body and this was a young woman
named christina weckler who was 20. now
she was found on a hillside near
glendale now this woman also raped also
strangled
also found nude now a new
detail a new wrinkle in this particular
case
was that there were some weird
injection marks on her arms now the
first thing cops thought was like oh
she's a drug addict but it wasn't like
that
um they're like it was just you didn't
have because you get drug addicts you
get like the track marks and all that
because they're like it wasn't like that
it was just like these weird like little
injection sites with like this fluid
oozing out of them
which spoiler alert turned out to be
windex
um because that was one of the things
you'll find out later like these two
guys were
amping it up they were trying different
things like different torture
methods and stuff like that like just to
get their jollies or whatever
so this was the first one that they
tried that on because apparently just
raping and strangling them wasn't
fun anymore so they just decided they
were gonna like [ __ ]
do some extra [ __ ] like these kind of
dudes do
so that was the next one now three days
after that november 23rd 1977
they found a young woman jane king
who was 28 years old now her body was
badly decomposed
found near an off-ramp near the golden
state freeway
now she had actually been missing since
november 9th she was an aspiring
actress and she had actually been taking
acting classes
at that big scientology center there in
la um and that was the place she was
last seen i think she was last seen like
leaving that place and like waiting to
get a bus
like to go back home or whatever and
that was the last time that she was seen
and then they found her on the 23rd
now at this stage the cops are pretty
certain that they're dealing with a
serial killer like i said they suspected
it was two guys they weren't
entirely sure but they were you know
that was what they were leaning toward
so at this point they're like okay well
we need to form like a [ __ ] tax
task force to like deal with this [ __ ]
so the media at this point also
got on the bus that they were like you
know this is a serial killer so they
call it the hillside strangler because
like i said the press didn't know at the
time that it was
that the cops were thinking that it was
two guys they were just thinking it was
one person so they call him the hillside
strangler
so only a few days later november 29th
1977
cops found another body this was lauren
wagner who was 18
years old uh she had also been strangled
with a ligature they also found
signs of torture on her as well but
different ones
she had burn marks on her hands not like
cigarette burns or anything like that
it was like and they wouldn't know until
they caught these two
[ __ ] later but apparently they were
trying to like
electrocute her like with [ __ ] the
cords like from the lamp or something
like that it's like they were trying to
like put them in her hands
like electrocuted they were just like
like i said they were just trying to
like torture people just like to get
their jollies
so that was another thing that they were
trying to do but they couldn't like the
cops couldn't figure it out for a long
time because they were like these really
weird like burn marks in the middle of
her hands
but they the two guys would like try to
electrocute her i don't think it worked
though
so um at this point like i said they're
you know they're thinking it's more than
one person
but they didn't really release that
information so
december 13th 1977 they found another
body
this was a 17 year old woman uh she was
also a sex worker her name was kimberly
martin
she i believe was i think how they got
her
was that one of them called because she
was a sex worker so i think he called
and like wanted her to come to a
particular place and then they like
you know kidnapped her and like took her
to a place and killed her
now the last victim uh at least of the
two of them
because like i said ken would go on to
like kill two other women on his own
but the last one of the canonical 10
that the two of them killed together
her body was found because it was a
couple month
reprieve her body was found february 16
1978 now this was um
a girl cindy hudspeth she was 20 years
old and she'd been missing for a little
while
um and they found her
she was in the trunk of her
car which was an orange datsun they
found it like
because when they were looking for the
helicopter saw this car that had been
like pushed off this ravine or whatever
and they went and found the car because
it was hers and they looked in the trunk
and her dead body was in there
1978 early 1978. i remember that [ __ ]
orange that datsun used to have is a
[ __ ]
nasty yellowish looking [ __ ] orange i
remember that
well yeah i've seen pictures of this
particular car but in the station wagon
was it well it was in a trunk so it
wasn't
could have been yeah no i thought it was
a hatchback but maybe i could be
remembering everything
like i thought she was like lois had one
of an orange dots and it was a station
wagon
yeah yeah it was that same [ __ ]
shitty ass orange
weird colors back in the 70s tila said
boy scientologists love some actors
don't they
i think what scientologists do because
we've done a bunch of shows about
scientologists no scientology well
like i said i i worked for them like
when i lived in clearwater
not for the church but for another
company that was owned by them what
one thing they like to do is that they
know that a lot of young people are
coming to
la and hollywood to be actors so
scientologists had the brainwave to
set up acting classes so they can like
funnel people
into scientology yeah and the reason why
they wanted them in scientology is
because
l ron hubbard thought that the more
actors he had
in scientology more the more clout and
the more power scientology would have
which was true that's true yeah they did
actually kind of work
yeah there are political parties and
intelligence agencies and everything
always want to recruit actors
to be mouthpieces for them um
laugh laugh all you want about [ __ ]
lrh or elrond hubbard
he wasn't dumb i mean that dude [ __ ]
did some [ __ ] i couldn't he was crazy
but yeah he was wrong about a lot um
but uh no he knew exactly how to
manipulate people and his organization
that church
did the largest something called snow
white operation snow white
it's the largest infiltration of the
[ __ ] fbi [ __ ] it's ever been
ever been done you know yep scientology
when it was strong and well-led
scientology was dangerous they almost
took over a country
yeah it was that it was an african
country remember which one it was yeah
something like that something like that
yeah they almost took over the entire
country as its official religion they
wanted to use it as a base
from there they would take over the
entire world religions political groups
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] it's all the
militaries it's all that same
method behind it it's not a joke
now was lrh a joke
kinda he understood the method by which
to gain power
but he himself wasn't really an
impressive guy really
storyteller science fiction writer
yeah um he did have willpower though
but scientology was built on the backs
of people with [ __ ]
weak personalities really that had a lot
to do with it
business said they took over clearwater
florida they did yeah pretty much the
entire
because i lived there for a little while
i lived in tampa
and then i got a job in clearwater um
which i didn't really grasp was like
owned by like everybody that not
everybody that worked there was a
scientologist but a lot of them were
like the upper management was
and um so after a while i was sick of
commuting from tampa to clear water so i
moved to like a smaller apartment in
clearwater to be closer to work
and i only lasted about eight months
there before i was like i gotta get out
of this place
crazy some crazy [ __ ] i'm just i'm
leaving they did not like it
secret bases out in the desert they got
[ __ ] that are like
prison compounds secret bases out in
[ __ ] california and [ __ ] up in the
mountains
uh they have secret religious prisons
where they have
their followers imprisoned i guess for
life
think of that yeah well they put i think
netflix or hulu has
um that's uh what's her name that did
the that series on uh
on scientology that used to be in there
what the [ __ ] her name
yeah i just thought of it oh man yeah
no not as a t what's the name tina
i'll probably think of it like 20
minutes from now um but yeah oh
bee's nest you just said something about
blue star ointment and that like
um like brought back some memories i
remembered that old like
that little jar that it used to be in
with like that sparkly like
blue asterisk on it it's that x-member
leah remedy leah remini thank you
thank you thank you that's leah
i thought i was thinking tila but leah
yeah
you were thinking about because there's
a tequila yeah
well there's a tila that we're talking
to yeah um yeah
leah leah remini yeah [ __ ]
i had angry gay pope we had angry gay
pope on the show tell you two or three
times two or three times
he'll tell you all about scientology
he's a professional scientology
protester yeah um
scientology is not what it was but it's
still a very
wealthy organization that owns lots of
property i would call it more like a
real estate scam right now
but at one time scientology was almost
like a nation state
inside the united states and a lot of
religions did that the mormons did that
islam is kind of like that
islam was like a nation-state that came
out of the middle east
a long time ago and it's still around it
religions are just like that when
they're set up well
you know yeah well and like i said i
think
everybody knows like i think most people
know scientology's joke nowadays but
yeah they didn't know it was a joke back
then
no well it wasn't i mean they actually
did they were able to do like some
[ __ ] crazy
i remember i remember being an outsider
and just
stumbling across scientology it was kind
of ominous it seemed like they knew
something that was you know i mean
that they had some kind of special
knowledge i had heard
rumors that they had mental powers and
something like out of the jedi
and i didn't doubt that after seeing
[ __ ] about mountain poltergeist
but now that i understand exactly what
after i saw south park then i was in
that south park episode
i think that south park episode like
went a long way toward
making them yeah a joke and like
demystified and
showing how stupid the whole thing was
you know what i mean
yeah which i don't know why people
didn't realize that prior to that
but they think they have force powers
yeah but
no they don't victor says we need to
start taxing all these religions i agree
they probably should yeah i don't know
why they don't but you know that's how
this [ __ ] goes
um all right so now the weird thing so
the last victim of
the hillside stranglers you know plural
was cindy
hud's beth now the weird thing about it
is that she was also she lived across
the street
from another one of the victims
christina weckler
so the cops not being dummies were kind
of like hey
maybe the killer lives in that area or
lives in the glendale area
because obviously that's too much of a
coincidence that both of these
women like lived right on the same
street
which is one of the things that would
cause them to get caught later on
so at this stage like i said they have
um a task force
now even though i feel like
what ended up happening and i just think
it particularly happened a lot in
california around this time period was
that you had all these kind of like
you know if the fbi gets brought in a
case or if you have like you know
steakhouse city cops and they're all
like
fighting with each other it's like they
don't want to share information because
like i said men are [ __ ]
so it's like and it really kind of like
hindered the investigation however i
will say that on the hillside strangler
case it seemed like
everyone kind of got their [ __ ] together
and there wasn't a lot
of inter departmental
bitching or fighting they pretty much
put their differences aside and two of
the main guys that were working on the
case um who was bob grogan who was like
a detective
and uh frank salerno um who i think was
from the la sheriff's department or was
the lapd i can't remember but
those two guys um actually got along
so they were actually instrumental in
kind of telling everybody hey
we're all working together on this like
let's not have any of this like [ __ ]
quarreling like then jealousy and [ __ ]
like that like they usually have which
kind of hindered the investigation so
they actually did kind of a good job in
this but
that said you also have to realize that
this is still the 1970s they didn't have
dna
they didn't have like a lot of the [ __ ]
that they have nowadays
so they were kind of hamstrung in that
regard so
i do kind of feel like even though i'm
quick to like [ __ ] on the cops when they
[ __ ] stuff up because they do in a lot
of these investigations
in this i think they did the best they
could
considering what was going on you know
what i'm saying
they did actually do the best they could
in this case so
basically after the last killing
even though they had all of these
departments like working together like
for a change
they didn't really seem to be going
anywhere like i said that's you know the
ninth victim and the tenth victim there
was like two months in between there and
then it was like going on and on and
they were like no more killings
and it was kind of i watched a couple
documentaries and they talked to like a
lot of the investigators on this case
and they're like you know one of them
was kind of like this is kind of shitty
to say but
he's like sometimes in cases like these
it's like you're not wishing that they
kill another person
but you kind of are because then you'd
have like new leads to follow and you'd
have like new because when they're not
doing anything when they're not active
you're kind of like spinning your wheels
you know what i mean he's like i know
that's terrible to say but that's kind
of like
you know was because you can't really do
anything so it had been like quite a
while and they're just like well
what happened like these dudes are not
active anymore so there's really like
nothing
that we can do they did actually get
something like you know and like i said
keep in mind this is the late 70s
they did actually kind of get like a
little bit of a profile going
but like a lot of the profiles then it
was kind of vague
like the profile was um this guy or guys
uh probably white because most of the
victims were except for the first one
who was african-american
um he's probably in his late 20s early
30s
they guessed that he was either single
separated or divorced and didn't live
with a woman
which in one case was incorrect
uh average intelligence unemployed or
existing on odd jobs or a person that
doesn't stay in one job too long like
moves around a lot
uh probably been in trouble with the law
before um passive
cold and manipulative which those
three things don't necessarily go
together but i don't know that was like
what they said
um probably from a broken home
probably had a childhood marked by
cruelty and brutality
uh probably had a mother that abused
them uh
someone that hated women or had like a
lot of early experiences where women
were mean to them or whatever
so that was kind of what they came up
with now the funny thing is that from
the book that darcy o'brien wrote about
this case which is kind of like the
definitive book about the hillside
strangler
um one of the investigators on the case
grogan was basically like so
gee all we have to do now is find a
white male who hates his mother
in l.a yeah
[Laughter]
they're like yeah tell me another one
let's narrow it down a little bit but
you couldn't
now here's something interesting this
wasn't in a lot of this stuff but they
actually this was in darcy o'brien's
book and they put this
in the tv movie from 1989 as well and
apparently this really happened
so this guy he was like kind of a famous
i can't remember what his name was but
he was like a famous
uh psychic he didn't speak any english
now he apparently had some thoughts
about the hillside strangler case and he
flew to los
angeles on his own dime and went to the
lapd
and said that he had some information
about the case and he couldn't speak any
english
so he had to like kind of he had like a
guy that worked at the police department
having to speak some german so he was
like kind of trying to translating
now the crazy thing is that this guy
said
that the killers were two italians
which they were and that they were
brothers close
cousins and he said they were about 35
which actually um ken i think when he
first moved to l.a he was 26 and angelo
was like 20 years older
you know what i mean so it's like right
in the middle of what made him think
they were italian
how do you call that isn't that weird i
don't even
i don't believe in psychics i don't know
that was like a lucky guess he was
claiming to be a psychic huh
yeah yeah he was like well known for
being a psychic and like i said he felt
so strongly about the
about this okay vision that he had that
was it he flew over here and said that
there are two italians and that they're
brothers and i'm like
declare that [ __ ] pretty close i can't
remember what that dudes put the psychic
crown on
he called it he did it he was very close
i understand it man i've had those
feelings too he had a feeling about it
he felt so strong he went down to go
tell him and like i said he paid for his
own ticket
to fly to l.a and tell them the problem
is
that that's not not enough information
to make an arrest well no because
there's a lot of italians in the u.s
yeah and there's a lot of brothers in
the
he was close and like i u.s they weren't
even brothers they were just doing what
he could do
which you know he probably thought like
i got to help them because like nothing
was like i said they had a task force
but it seemed like nothing was happening
with the [ __ ] because
they hadn't killed anybody in a long
time so
months go by like i said there's no new
crimes
so at this point the task force they
have no new leads there are no new
crimes to investigate
so they're like well basically there's
nothing else that they could do
so they dispersed the task force like
you do after a while if there's nothing
new to work on
however then a little bit later
there came a break in the case very
early
in 1979 january 12th as a matter of fact
there were some cops in a little town
called bellingham washington
now what happened in bellingham was that
there were these two women who were
students at western washington
university they were roommates
their names were karen mandick and diane
wilder
now they turned up missing
and according to all their friends and
family uh they were like these were not
the type of
girls that would just like wander off
and not tell anybody what they were
doing like you know one of them didn't
show up to work the next day and ever so
everyone got really worried about it
so basically what ended up happening
with that
is that they found out through talking
to friends and family of
the girls that one of the young women
had accepted a house-sitting job uh in
a neighborhood called bayside which i
guess was kind of an upper middle class
neighborhood
she was trying to make some extra money
so she was going to house it at this
place
um and she and they said that she had
got the job from this guy that she knew
that was like a security guard
right so the cops
call the security firm that this dude
supposedly works for
so the security firm calls him
and says hey what is it about this house
sitting job for one of our clients
he's like oh i don't know what you're
talking about um
i've never heard of those two girls
whatever i see
that wasn't me i said i wasn't even
anywhere in the area i was at this
meeting like the sheriff's reserve
meeting or whatever like when that whole
[ __ ] was going
down so i don't know why you're
bothering me so the cops investigated
further because at this point they're
very interested and they're like okay
well they found out that that security
guard in particular
was actually not at the meeting as he
had said he had been um
so they decided they were going to go
check this dude out
rather because they had been contacting
him through the firm that he worked for
prior to this
so they go uh to investigate him in
person
and they find that he's just this lovely
friendly young dude named ken
bianchi now he said that he didn't go to
the meeting
after all because it was about some [ __ ]
that he already knew and he thought it
was a waste of time now
at this stage the two girls had not been
found
so they were not necessarily operating
on the assumption that the two girls had
been killed
um they were just like well maybe maybe
they just wandered off maybe you know
[ __ ] happens or whatever
so they weren't necessarily coming at it
from the foul play
angle but the police chief of bellingham
was kind of like nah i'm getting a bad
feeling about this we need to like lean
hard on this dude and see what the [ __ ]
happened because
i think these girls like something bad
happen to these girls i think it's a
kidnapping and murder situation
so he goes to the girls house like i
said they were roommates
and they found um the girl's cat
who was like starving like the cat was
still alive but
this cat was like obviously like really
well cared for so they thought it was
strange that the cat hadn't been fed in
a couple of days
and while they were in the house they
also found a piece of paper
that had the address of the house in
bayside where one of the girls was
supposedly
had got this house setting job so
they also found some records of the
of ken bianchi's name like in the same
paperwork
and they found the address of the place
like i said where they were going to
house it
so another thing that they found very
interesting was that ken bianchi
um he had used the company truck the
night that the two girls disappeared
on the excuse that he was going to take
it
to get serviced but when they went to
the service thing that the
firm used they were like yeah that dude
never showed up here so again they were
like
very interesting so basically then
he goes to um they go to
the house where the girl went to house
sit
now they didn't find anything in the
house in particular
except for like a wet footprint but
they didn't know who that belonged to
and it wasn't like any big thing it
wasn't like any evidence but they didn't
find anything
suspicious now another thing they found
while they were investing in this
particular house was that there was a
neighbor who lived like next door or
across the street or something like that
and that person said to the cops they
said you know the security guard
told me that i should check on this
house like every night because i guess
it was like under construction or nobody
was home or something like that
they said they should check they told me
i should check on this house like every
night
except for that night when those girls
disappeared
because the security guard told me that
they were installing a new alarm system
at this house and maybe
like i would get in trouble like
somebody would think i was breaking in
or something like that so they told me
not to
check on it that particular night so
again police thought that was very
suspicious
now after that the cops they still
haven't found the girls at this point
the girls are still missing
so finally they go to the media and um
they described the missing women they
discussed they um
karen mandick's car they gave a
description of that as well
and uh shortly after that was publicized
a woman called in
and said yes somebody left a car that
looks like that like
near my house it was kind of like out in
a remote area like out in the woods
so the cops go out there they find the
car inside the car
are the bodies of karen mandic and diane
wilder
both had been strangled and had had
other
injuries inflicted upon them as well
now at this stage they're pretty sure
that ken bianchi is their dude
now this is only like a day or two after
the murder
so um so they go and pick him up
he seems totally friendly and totally
um and so let's talk about
i kind of want to get into ken bianchi's
background i want to talk about angela
bono as well because we haven't really
talked about like them as people i was
just kind of talking about the case what
about that drink you want me to give you
some more of that yeah that'd be good
you can refill that all right but yeah
so they uh
pick him up and bring him in now
interestingly they couldn't obviously
hold him on
the murder charge because he didn't have
enough evidence however when they
searched his house they found a bunch of
stolen [ __ ] like because that was one
thing that he did when he was
that's why he liked working as a
security guard because he could like
steal [ __ ] from like the properties that
he was
security guarding at so the fact that
they found a bunch of stolen
in his house meant that they could hold
him on that while they were
investigating him for the murder so
that's what they did
so let's talk about ken bianchi now at
the time that he was arrested
um unlike what the profiler said
about him being single or divorced or
whatever he actually did live he wasn't
married but he lived with his
girlfriend kelly boyd and they had a
son who was still a baby at this point
now people that they talk to including
the girlfriend
including other people at the security
firm all this other kind of [ __ ]
they simply could not believe that ken
bianchi
could be involved in a murder because he
seemed so
gentle and he seemed so friendly and he
didn't seem like he had
an evil angry bone in his body
so everyone just thought this has got to
be a mistake
right so that's kind of what everybody
thought
so basically though um
the investigation that they've done and
like i said you know the cops actually
did do a pretty thorough job this time
both in la
and in uh bellingham washington where
these two crimes took place
they pretty much every single hair every
single little piece of carpet fiber
every everything they were very very
very careful about collecting
every single minuscule piece of evidence
that they could collect
i mean when they were taking the bodies
out of the car where they were found
they would like they put them all in
these big like huge sheets so that
anything that fell onto their like any
kind of fiber or anything because they
got like a bunch of pubic hairs
they got like a bunch of um like fabric
type of fibers and stuff and they all
like fell in the sheet and they kept
like [ __ ] all of it
and they even found like a bunch of
pubic hairs like
um i think they found like on the front
steps of like the house and bayside
where she had gone to
um house sit so they found all that [ __ ]
so um they also found like the
the fibers that were in there were like
on the carpet like from the bayside
house
they matched the fibers that were found
on um the bodies like diane
wilder's body that was found in the car
and um so
basically they had like a lot of
forensic evidence in this case
um but you know it it takes a few days
to like sort that all out because they
have to like send it to the lab and why
not
so as i said they were keeping kenny in
custody under
you know theft because he had stolen a
bunch of [ __ ] from his uh security guard
job so they were keeping it in there
like
while being suspicious that he had
something to do with the murders as well
now the police chief in bellingham was
no slouch and
he was like okay well here's these two
young women
that disappeared and then were found
strangled
um i remember that in la
there was these 10 women that were found
strangled
and looking at ken bianchi's driver's
license
he's like this dude used to live in l.a
too
so so like i said no slouch
so he calls up la and he's like hey um
we just arrested this dude up here
on suspicion of a double murder and
we're wondering if maybe he has
something to do with that [ __ ] that you
were dealing with down there
so they kind of like got together on
that now
interestingly when they looked into ken
bianchi's background
they found that two of the victims
who like i said had lived across the
street from each other cindy hudsbeth
and christina weckler
lived on east garfield street they're
like um
yeah so did ken bianchi
used to live on east garfield street in
fact he was the next door neighbor
of christina weckler i let pookie out
too oh okay
so they're like okay that's a little
weird and also one of the other victims
kimberly martin who was a sex worker
um one of the the last call that she was
called on like she was called from a pay
phone
the apartment that she was uh summoned
to was on tamarind
avenue and even though the apartment
that she was called to was
found to be a vacant apartment at that
point ken bianchi and his girlfriend
lived in that same apartment building so
they're like okay well that cannot be a
coincidence so this dude
is for sure like one of the
[ __ ] that we're looking for
so so then they all started coordinating
because they're like okay well we need
to like
investigate all the [ __ ] he was doing in
l.a and all the [ __ ] that we're doing in
bellingham because we're sure
that this is one of the hillside
stranglers so
they put together um they also found
during the search of ken bianchi's house
they also found some jewelry
a turquoise ring that had belonged to
first victim
yolanda washington and they found a
necklace
that had belonged to kimberly martin who
was one of the last victims
uh and also all of the pubic hair and
[ __ ] like that they found at the
bellingham
house matched ken bianchi as well so
they had him like dead to rights so like
i said let's kind of talk about
his background now ken bianchi
um was originally from rochester new
york and like i said
the alphabet murders which we did a show
about like quite a while ago
uh that took place in rochester which
are still unsolved
um he is also a suspect in those
as well um at least two of them because
i think carmen cologne that's
probably more likely that her uncle did
that but i think the other two
are still like up for grabs so ken
bianchi
um not excusing his ass or anything like
that but he didn't really have a great
start in life so his mom
was a sex worker and also a drunk and
she i don't know who the father was
nobody knows
so she basically she had the kid and
then she was like
said to a friend of hers or neighbor or
something like here you take care of him
and just like basically
gave him away um so when he was
three months old uh he was adopted
by francis bianchi and uh i think his
dad's name was nicholas
who was like a he worked at like a shoe
foundry or something like that
now this this i found very interesting i
guess like from talking to
his parents or at least his adoptive mom
because his dad died when he was still
when he was a teenager
his mom pretty much knew that there was
something wrong with him
from like a pretty young age they're
like even when he was a little kid
like by the time he started talking like
when he was a toddler
all the kid did was lie so he was like a
pathological
liar um and basically
he was just kind of like he was real
lazy he wouldn't like apply
himself like he seemed perfectly his
intelligence is actually a little bit
above average
but he just would never apply himself to
anything he didn't really seem to give a
[ __ ] about anything
when he was five and a half uh his
adoptive mom
thought that something was the matter
with him because he would go into these
weird like trance states
you know what i mean so they so she
actually took him to a doctor it was
that serious
um the doctor thought that he was having
seizures like petty mouth
seizures because like his eyes would
roll back in his head and stuff so they
thought something was matter but the
doctor was like
he was kind of like yeah it's that but i
don't think it's anything to worry about
like he'll probably grow out of it
right which okay um which i i guess so
but uh so as i said he goes to school he
didn't really
you know he was he was smart but he
wasn't real he was a real underachiever
kind of thing he was just kind of lazy
not real into it um he was also
uh real he had anger issues like he was
real
quick to get mad about stuff he had like
tantrums even like into his
height into his high school years um he
got
sent to a shrink like his mom so like i
said i think and you have to think that
this is like the 50s and 60s
um taking your kid to a shrink that's
like a big deal
that was kind of a big deal so this kid
must have been like
really acting up because i feel like a
lot of parents would have been just like
oh they're a brat whatever
maybe not but i i kind of feel like that
wasn't a thing like nowadays if your
kids act
like everybody knows and like you take
them to a therapist or whatever but back
then in the 50s and 60s
this would have been the 60s because he
was born in 1951. that's only rich
families though doing that
taking their kids or that or the kids
just really [ __ ] up yeah the kids
really [ __ ] up yeah but i'm just
saying that he must have been like
really
unusual because i'm [ __ ] up because i
feel like
that was just something that wasn't real
widespread back then especially
this particular family who were kind of
working class they weren't like it
wasn't an upper middle class family or
anything like that
yeah you know what i mean out of
mississippi if you were [ __ ] up back
then they just pray over you
and just take you to church and pray on
you because they thought you were
possessed you'll be all right yeah
it's just sin that's awesome yeah you
just got a little sin here you gotta get
that out of there that's awesome
but yeah so uh so yeah the psychologist
was like well
um the psychologist basically said that
he was overly dependent on his mother
yeah even though even though it's weird
because he seemed to like also hate his
mother
like both of these two guys really
really really seem to have a problem
with women
sound like mama boys to me they both and
also they both really seem to have
madonna horror complexes maybe
like ken for sure like i think that was
like a big
i think that's a side effect of being a
mama's boy though of having like a weird
yeah because you either think women are
trash or don't where they are
or they're like they're not ideal like
mama yeah
but then they hate their mom at the same
time it's totally bizarre
but i think that's basically well ken
had that like in [ __ ] spades
and he um he also got sent to a catholic
elementary school which i guess is a
private school and that was like a big
deal because like i said this was like a
working-class family he didn't have a
lot of money so they were trying to like
[ __ ] straighten his ass out i'm not
sure if that [ __ ] exists anymore
i think that was something that happened
back in the day with the culture and the
expectations of the day
yeah probably they're probably not
around anymore porn probably got rid of
all that
yeah i think i think the proliferation
of porn has really been like
a good for society as a whole it might
be i mean
in a lot of ways i think it is because
it normalizes a lot of things
yeah that were that would give people
complexes before
yeah back then you know what i mean
society would make them have complexes
this is bad you can't have this yeah
because it's not normal it is
yeah you must be crazy if you like that
right which
you know and you know there's a blow job
well there's something wrong with you
yeah i mean yes there's a whole other
discussion to be having like i don't
like the idea of people having to do
porn against their will
obviously that's a whole different issue
but i'm just talking about people that
do porn you know that are of age and
that
chose to do it i definitely think that
that is
that i think it's it's good because like
i said before
back in the 50s or something if you were
into like some weird [ __ ] if you were a
furry or something for example
they had those in the 50s i don't know
probably all right dude there's nothing
new
you have to send your ass to a
psychologist that's what i mean
everybody would think there was
something wrong with you you wouldn't
like realize that
like other people had the same thing and
it's fine you know what i mean
you're on medication yeah they would
think that there was something to matter
with you that you were a deviant
yeah so i fee i feel like that you know
that stigma
being gone is like is good i think
that's that's
good for people yeah i'm gonna go back
to what i said before i still have my
own [ __ ] personal [ __ ] thomas ross
theory
that unleaded gasoline had a lot to do
with this [ __ ] or excuse me leaded
gasoline had a lot to do with this oh i
don't doubt it
i don't [ __ ] put lead in gasoline
yeah back in the days
because it quick and made the valves
[ __ ] run a little more silent it
would
i remember [ __ ] taking old engines
apart you'd see a little ring of lead
around where the valves on the [ __ ]
head
and uh it was a [ __ ] brilliant idea
what some jackal came up the idea of
putting [ __ ] lead particles inside
gasoline
those lead particles are blowing out
around all blowing out of all the
[ __ ] exhaust pipes and the ship was
[ __ ] collected and all the [ __ ]
high-density traffic areas
cities lead particles well and you have
to think too oracle just mentioned like
lead paint like a lot paint and houses
had lead in it too and like little
babies were like [ __ ] eating that of
like peeling it off the walls and eating
it [ __ ] like lead costs
just ask the romans the romans ate off
oh yeah for sure gives you brain damage
for sure
and especially if you're exposed to it
when you're a child
like [ __ ] it will [ __ ] your brain up
yeah the romans
ate off lead plates and they also
sprinkled [ __ ] lead dust sometimes on
[ __ ] foods because they didn't have
salt and pepper well they had it but
they didn't really have salt
give it a little spice no spices really
so a little brain damage on top
they liked how lead tasted delicious
brain damage
and it was funny because you know all
the rich and ruling class people were
[ __ ] nuts
well they also had [ __ ] easier access
to [ __ ] lead
i think lead had a lot to do with the
[ __ ] insanity
you saw from ancient rome victor said
that water pipes that on uh last podcast
on the left they also talked about
leaded gasoline
that's good okay okay you tell them that
[ __ ] are geniuses
i've never heard i didn't hear that
episode but i i really like ledbot last
pocket jesus
i was actually kind of looking when i
was first like watching documentaries
about this i was looking to see if they
had done a show in the hillside
stranglers but they i didn't see one on
youtube
when i was a kid man i'd fill up my cars
let it gasoline every now and then i'd
get a whiff of [ __ ] gasoline
or be around a car that was running and
you would get
[ __ ] lightheaded sometimes yeah you'd
have like this weird taste in your mouth
that went for a long time is that
[ __ ] leaded gasoline yeah
maybe that [ __ ] explains me and
[ __ ] some of the crazy [ __ ] i did
when i was young
that would explain a lot having some of
that [ __ ] lid that would explain a
lot yeah
it takes a long time to piss it out of
your system
but yeah so okay so he goes to a
catholic elementary school like i said
his
parents had to pay for it and [ __ ] now
uh his dad whose adopted dad
uh died i believe when ken was 13.
uh at which point uh his mom had to
support the family
and uh she got a job like at a i don't
remember where she got a job at she was
some kind of factory or something like
that to like support them
now he went to high school not a real
you know he wasn't like a you know a
bully or anything like that he was just
like
no distinction whatsoever now one thing
that
in darcy o'brien's book that he pointed
out um and this is kind of going back to
what we're saying about the madonna
horror complex
is that ken had a very let's call it a
complicated
relationship with women in general um he
basically
what he would do i kind of feel like he
put
women on a pedestal but
he had like all these really idealized
like they have to be
perfect they have to be beautiful they
have to be virginal
they have to be completely loyal to me
and do whatever like he didn't have to
be like that
obviously like he could just look like a
[ __ ] dork and like he could
have a bunch of girlfriends at one time
but of course
the woman couldn't have that you know i
mean so he had like a real big like
double standard going
um and he didn't like
he didn't like them to be like sluttily
dressed i guess he didn't like any of
that kind of like 60s
like oh their pants are too tight and
all this so he had this weird
like idealized version of the way and
and anytime like a woman did something
he didn't like he just
was like it was this huge betrayal even
though like i said he could do whatever
he wanted like he could screw around on
his girlfriends he could do
he could do that but she wasn't allowed
to he had what they call toxic
masculinity
that's why oh these two big time wait
till we talk about angelo bono
that dude was toxic masculine in the
dictionary next to that there's a
picture of angelo buono
but this guy was like no [ __ ] prize
either i gotta say
you know what i mean yeah so
now he actually got married
when he graduated from high school in
1991
however the marriage i believe only
lasted eight months
before she packed up and left because
she was like [ __ ] this dude
now according to him oh she just left
with no reason i'm like
i doubt that that's true i'm sure she
had a [ __ ] reason
but uh considering like all the [ __ ]
that he got up to later on
but so he of course was heartbroken
about it because he's like oh those
horrible [ __ ]
they betrayed me because as i said he
can do whatever he wanted but she
couldn't do whatever she
so he was like an [ __ ] to her and she
took off and left and suddenly that was
hurtful because that's kind of how he
thought so
now he starts going to community college
shortly after this now like many serial
killers
he was a cop groupie he wanted to be a
cop
damn well they like the power that's why
hopefully everybody's hearing us
why because i left [ __ ] youtube and
trying to get back in youtube's locked
up on my tablet
it's just youtube doesn't like you yeah
i'm trying to get back into it i'm gonna
reset my [ __ ] maybe it's my tab
yeah reset your [ __ ] yeah
but uh yeah so he starts taking courses
in uh police science and psychology
and even though he seemed like pretty
interested in that [ __ ] like he was just
like
like
i said he was really kind of lazy and an
underachiever so he was just like [ __ ]
this this go into school kind of [ __ ] i
can't deal with it so he just like
dropped out
now he applied for a job at the
sheriff's department but
was rejected so he ended up working as a
security guard which as i mentioned
earlier oh thank you victor
good show tom pissed off youtube yeah
what else is he doing you'll hear me so
it must be working what else is next
my tablet oh was that what that noise
was starting okay i was like what's that
weird noise coming from over there
thank you victor good show i'm actually
i feel like i'm still kind of
sober and still kind of on topic which
is amazing even though it took us like
almost an hour to get to the topic but
whatever well it usually takes us that
to warm up
it it does actually we should probably
worry about pre-show we should warm up
like before the show but i guess not
because i guess people like that
so he so he starts working as a security
guard now like i mentioned earlier
he really dug working as a security
guard because it was kind of like being
a cop
and also because you get to wear a suit
well yeah you
well and also uh you got to like guard
stuff and no one else was around so you
could steal [ __ ]
yeah so that was another thing that he
really liked so he
um so one job that he had was he was a
security guard at a jewelry store and he
really liked that because then he could
steal all kind of like jewelry and like
give it to his girlfriends and stuff
um so i thought that was like really
funny now at this point he's still
in rochester new york and he's like okay
well
this [ __ ] place is going nowhere i
really need to get the [ __ ] out of here
so at this point
i don't know if he decided on his own
to move to la with angelo buono his
cousin
or if his mom made him go like i've
heard both versions it doesn't really
matter
1975 he's 26 years old and he goes
to live in l.a now he moves in
with angelo bono who is his cousin like
i said he's about 20 years
older now when he first gets to
california
he's like super jazzed because it's like
oh man it's california in the [ __ ]
70s man it's like you [ __ ] hippie
chicks everywhere as
drugs it's like it's super fun and uh so
he's having a really good time
and i mean honestly you have to say too
that
you mentioned it earlier but angelo bono
who
was older but he was also kind of he was
like such
he was an italian american and he was
such
he's like the classic guido he for sure
like
thought that he was he liked to pretend
that he was like all mobbed up and [ __ ]
he had like the [ __ ] you know dyed
black hair he had like the [ __ ]
gold chains like with the uns he had all
that [ __ ] going on okay it's like he had
all that kind of stuff
so back in the 70s i guess that was
pretty impressive especially for
somebody like ken who
i don't know if i'd call ken naive
necessarily but i think that he
at first i think that he did kind of
idolize
angelo yeah just because angelo
as shitty and we'll get into this a
little bit later on as shitty a person
as angela was just in every
metric possible for some reason like
teenage girls seem to [ __ ] love him
not older women because older women like
he had no you know
but you know teenage girls that were
still kind of naive i guess
they thought that he was the [ __ ] even
though he's ugly as hell but yeah
something out of the movies
i guess yeah because i guess he was like
kind of confident and cocky and [ __ ] and
they thought that
they thought that that meant that he was
like cool even though he was like i said
he's the [ __ ] worst yeah like some of
the movies some of the time
i guess yeah yeah he was like a [ __ ]
mobster
or whatever no if angelo's close
tony's even more that's even more
mobster
tony tony and angelo yeah
[Laughter]
thinking about all the [ __ ]
so yeah so ken comes out there he moves
in with angelo they start
hanging out together now as i said ken
was a police groupie
so he tries at first he applies for the
lapd they didn't have any
jobs available so then he applies at the
glendale police department but
his interview didn't go so well i've
actually heard some audio
they still had audio of his job
interview
at the glendale police department and
the guy that interviewed him said
it's like he didn't come off as like a
dick or anything like that they're like
he just came across as very
shallow like he didn't really mean
anything that he said
like he's very surface level he was
larping and that's well yeah and it's
really interesting because one of the
girls that he ended up killing later on
he was like his neighbor
she um i guess he had maybe asked her
out or something she turned him down or
whatever she thought he was creepy
but um she wrote in her book that she
thought he was like quote unquote a used
car salesman
and that's what a lot of people said
that he came across as very phony
you know what i mean that he was just
like trying to be something that he
would yeah like his friendliness came
across as very forced or like he was
like fake yeah i mean that he came
across like that they normally are
yeah i've said that before the earlier
shows because they don't know how to be
a person yeah
listen to you listen to them they have
this they have the same delivery as a
pathological liar
yeah you ever run across a pathological
liar which ken was as well
yeah they're just and we'll get into
that later like there's certain
mannerisms and certain ways of
delivering things it's a pattern you can
see it and [ __ ]
a bunch of different people like casey
anthony who's a local [ __ ]
pathological liar remember casey anthony
yeah yeah i remember that
we should probably do a show about that
one of these days yeah if you ever see
it even
let me write that down because i might
forget yeah she's from around here
yeah last i heard casey anthony is
working
as a um
somebody you can you you could cuddle
with that as they were she's working off
of craigslist oh like a cuddle like a
cuddle buddy
like a cuddle buddy yeah which that
that's probably you from euphemism for
dick sucker but
that's what she's doing i always
wondered how much that cuddle buddy
thing would pay how much would people
pay just to be
cuddled boy although i do feel like
that's kind of like a work around for
like
a sex worker you won i'm just cuddling
people they're paying me for the
cuddling if we have sex later
that's just that's not anything to do
with it see it's a loophole somehow or
another
this was like after remember she got she
got acquitted
and she came up in a conversation of
something that i was reading online
and somebody posted a link says i think
this is her
and it went to a craigslist ad that was
around here
like tavares or some [ __ ] like that oh
yeah that's not far from here yeah like
tavares
and [ __ ] and it was like some cuddle
body [ __ ] you looked at the photograph
and they go like that does look like
casey anthony
yeah beezna said i'll cuddle her buddies
yeah
i [ __ ] killed her kid man probably
we should like i said it's been a long
time since i read about that case but we
probably should talk about that at some
point
that kid was found in her trunk yeah
if i remember correctly wouldn't it yeah
yeah yeah if that's the right case yeah
so i don't know how you get out i've
read so many cases i get like i don't
know
how you get out of that if they found a
dead kid in my trunk i'd be going to
[ __ ] prison
well that's kind of the case of pretty
much anybody yeah
you don't want a dead kid in your trunk
yeah i don't understand how she got out
of that one
said her dad did it i mean unless
somebody get that a bit
right it's like unless you could say oh
somebody else didn't put him in there to
like to frame me
okay which could happen it's just really
unlikely i think she was a hooker to
begin with if you ask me
maybe but like i said i'm not that's why
she was tying the kid up and putting the
kid in the trunk
so she could go out and do business see
that's a kid out there too long and it
cooked because apparently uh cutters
aren't a thing
she forget yeah she fell asleep or
something it had to be something like
that it's sad though because some people
do like [ __ ] and in florida for real
you can't leave your kid in the [ __ ]
car
[ __ ] no you'd cook that kid you can't or
a dog or a kid nothing you can't leave
anything in a car it's like an oven
even like for not that long so all right
so basically
ken tries to get a job at the police
department no one's having him
so he gets a job working for like a
title company
now he gets his first paycheck and he
gets this apartment
on east garfield avenue which like i
said two of the victims one of the
victims lived like next door
or you know in the same apartment
complex and one of the other victims
later victims lived across the street
although they didn't like know each
other
so he also bought i don't know how much
this [ __ ] paycheck was but he bought
he got an apartment and then he got
a car like it was a used car it was it
was a 1972 cadillac
um but that was another thing that a lot
of people said that was just kind of
like
he was uh not real good with money
clearly so he gets one paycheck and he's
like oh i'm gonna get an apartment i'm
gonna get a car i don't care a bunch of
costs i'm in debt whatever
so um as i said now one of the girls
that lived
next door in the apartment complex
christina weckler who he would end up
killing later on
uh kind of like tried to ask her out and
she was like nah i'm not having it and
she later that when
after she was dead they found that she
had written about him in her date book
and
that she said that he was like a used
car salesman
now at this point ken moves in because
like i said he'd been living with angelo
buono his cousin
um but he had met this uh young woman
at work kelly boyd and they moved in
together
in and in may of 1977 she got pregnant
with their son so
apparently he wanted to marry kelly she
didn't really want to marry him
probably because she knew what to do she
was i don't really know
now he app he didn't like he wasn't
abusive toward her
you know apparently but she there was a
lot of things about him that she didn't
like
she said he was like really uh jealous
which uh she wasn't a fan of
also he was real he was a liar like he
was a pathological liar like i said uh
also very immature
and he wasn't real good with money was
he was irresponsible
so she was kind of like yeah i don't
know if i want to tie myself to this
dude
so he actually ended up getting fired
because they found some pot in his desk
which again
dumb don't take your pot to work come on
you know better than that
maybe it was planted i
i bet it wasn't i mean how much would
somebody want to
[ __ ] you up to do that i'm not saying
it's impossible
i'm just saying i'm very very skeptical
that's what i would have said it was
planted i didn't do that
yeah but that's what they all say that's
why the joke is
it's even it's a joke at this point like
if cops
find drugs on you it's not mine even
it's in your pockets
these aren't my pants yeah that's it's
funny to them because
everybody [ __ ] says that because what
else are you gonna say they find the
drugs on you what else can you say
yeah you know if you're not gonna admit
it it's not mine somebody must have put
it in my pocket while i wasn't looking
so yeah somebody put some pot in his
desk while he wasn't looking but yeah he
got fired
so uh but he actually a little while
later he got another job
in downtown la and they moved to the
apartment at tamarand avenue which like
i said that was where one of the other
later victims got called to later on now
another interesting thing while he was
having a legitimate job here's some
other [ __ ] that ken bianchi was up to
one thing that he did he decided because
he had taken
like part of one psychology class like
back in community
community college like back in rochester
yeah yeah
so he i don't think he finished the
[ __ ] year maybe he didn't even finish
the semester i don't know
he decides he's going to set up a fake
psychologist's office
he's ready knows everything about
psychology
dunning-kruger syndrome it's a [ __ ] but
yeah so he decides he knows everything
about psychology and he's gonna set up a
[ __ ] office
so he sent off like he got a fake
degree like i don't know if he printed
or if he bought it from somewhere or
whatever so he got like a fake degree
and like a bunch of credit so he put him
like in frames and [ __ ]
and then he rented this office space
from like a legit psychologist and like
set up a [ __ ] psychologist's office
and like had some patience like i don't
think he had that many but
people like came to him and he pretended
to be a psychologist well scientologists
kind of do the same
well they do yeah but look how that goes
yeah
so just saying but yeah and so this
guy's a serial killer although i can't
tell you
i kind of doubt psycho certain aspects
of psychology too i think it's i don't
think it's a science i think it's more
of a philosophy
or an art form there is a certain amount
of
i'm not saying like there is a certain
amount of
uh interpretation of culture i think
there's a little bit of flim-flam with
that
and you know just me saying that
psychiatrists say that i remember when
psychiatrists would [ __ ] just
laugh at psychologists it took time for
psychology to be
accepted well it's not a hard science
for sure it's not a hard science
no i mean psychiatry is more like
studying like the
hard work yeah
they would [ __ ] laugh at
psychologists psychology is
psychology is accepted because it's
taught in universities
that's why well like i said it does have
it's not saying much
well yeah but it does have some i mean
some points of it do
it does have some merit and some people
do benefit from therapy but it is
but it is a very it's a soft science way
yeah
i'm gonna say it's more like a religion
or a philosophy
there's [ __ ] you can't prove you can't
prove what's happening what what a
person's thinking
um yeah there's a lot of patterns to
behavior
but that's not really a science i
understand what you're talking about
though
yeah yeah i understand something it can
it i think maybe
it can help you in general to guide you
along to be able to say yeah like if
you're this person is one of these kinds
of personalities
and like i said a lot of people benefit
from it i think that a lot of people
benefit from therapy
yeah mostly because it's nice
that they have some because somebody
just mentioned in the comments that it's
nice to have somebody to like
listen to you without like judging or
without yeah and it's like tr
actually listening and helping you out
which a lot of people don't have in
their
preacher does the same thing or a priest
does the same thing yeah but the whole
priest thing
that is that's some judgment judgment
is attached to that yeah so i think the
thing about psychology is that you're
having somebody listen to your problems
without coming out and saying oh you're
a sinner or are you this
and that there's no like judgment
attached to it you know what i'm saying
i don't think
i don't think the second priests are
like that either i think they have
trainees in psychology a lot of them
well some of them do it depends on the
denomination yeah depends on the
denomination
but um suspect of all that [ __ ]
you know what i mean because it's like
you said it's not a hard science
it's not sure what's happening it's like
history victor said you can call a sex
line
they'll listen to you it's just like
history it's cheaper probably
history is an art form it's not a hard
science either
it's telling stories you can take
different
periods in history and then
kind of what i say
reboot them with different narratives to
tell a totally different story than what
another history would say
there you know i mean i'm talking about
well it's people that weren't there it's
really
hard to well and i think what a lot of
historians try to do then
is that they try to read a lot of
different sources from that time period
and try to like
eek out like what actually probably was
most likely to have happened
because like i said unless until you can
invent a time machine and go back and
actually see what happened
you don't really know so the only thing
you can do is read a bunch of people's
perspectives on what happened and then
try to figure out
but you can give a person to go in there
with using some certain kinds of
critical
theory and then come about and
reinterpret that history
to mean something that it does not mean
i've seen him do it
you know what i mean you know what i'm
talking about yeah yeah i do
yeah you can you can you can put a spin
on history yeah i know
to get everybody knows that whatever
what any narrative you want
i mean that that was even going back
into ancient times in rome in roman
history
like sweet sweet tony switonius and the
other roman hit
roman writers they were spinning the
history of their time
didn't necessarily mean that it happened
that way that's just the way that
they want you to believe that it went
down and it's usually for politic
political reasons but like i said humans
are not the any different now than they
were
yeah they're exactly the same same [ __ ]
happens yeah so
like i said and like i said i kind of
put it uh good historians know that
which is why they usually will try to
read a lot of different sources and then
try to puzzle out what happened from
that
rather than just going by one dude's
like so that's why i like to say things
like psychology
it's an interpretation of what you're
sure it's not necessarily
well and like i said particularly and
we'll get into it a little bit um when
we talk about these [ __ ] trial
um that's why both the prosecution and
the defense will have their own
psychologists their own psychiatric
experts because
it can be interpreted in one way or
another way like that is you know uh
advantageous you want to know the truth
you get you gotta have to [ __ ]
consult the writings of lrh l ron
hubbard
tom suddenly became a scientologist
right here on this show
l ron hubbard will tell you you better
not
become
will dictate reality to you
then you will understand
yep xenu and the volcano it's all true
that that's the hidden that's the hidden
history that's only for
well how come i know about it then
because i'm [ __ ] special that
that [ __ ] that that tech got squirreled
it did
it got squirreled yeah they have their
own whole
lingo yeah yeah isn't that sad tech was
scoring and like i said i worked for
them for so long and like i've
subsequently like read so much about
them that i that i know all their
[ __ ] lego you must learn the art of
postulation
you must be able to postulate i'm such a
suppressive person
give me the [ __ ] clay figurines we're
gonna [ __ ] play with play-doh
right yeah we're gonna rehearse the
conversation that was like the first
thing that i was just kind of like
i'm sitting in this workplace i'm like
is this a mental hospital like what the
[ __ ] is going on right now
and like i even asked somebody later i'm
like what the [ __ ] was that all about is
this kindergarten now did i not know
like where i'm working or something
because i'm an [ __ ] like that
and uh they're like no we're like we're
we're posh we have to like make clay
figures this is a representation of this
person that i have a problem with and
i'm like
yeah do you not have an imagination part
of our communication training
we will learn how to communicate yeah
that's that's what i have to say let's
take the communication in case
if you're listening to the audio thing
i'm making the jack off motion
he once tried to recruit me i didn't
even know what the [ __ ] what it was when
i was in boston i was walking down
newbury street
[ __ ] right near near tower records
and some [ __ ] pretty girl walked up
and said
we should come in for a personality test
and he goes no i don't need a
personality test
you don't need a person i said no i know
how i am yeah
and my personality is the kind of person
that's like [ __ ] off yeah i know exactly
how i am
that's what my personality yeah the [ __ ]
out of my face
i don't want anything to do with this
yeah
and then [ __ ] she's asking me more
and more about myself and
she realized i'd just come out of the
army and and and i told her i said yeah
i just came out of the arm because
oh yeah our art the founder of our
institute was ex-navy so he
said he was the best person ever so he
was kind of like
kind of like what you're talking about
kind of like that kind of like what
you're talking about it was like
yeah he was like a pretend military yeah
so it's kind of the same kind of the
same
hilarious oh my god we could talk about
[ __ ] scientology all day it's one of
them it's one of my favorite subjects
just because i [ __ ] hate them so much
i'd like to
we gotta do another show outside we
should probably do another show about so
you know what i mean because
there's always like new [ __ ] to talk
about we never talked about
the occult nature of scientology where
it comes from and
how we talked about it a little bit on
the aleister crowley
show um because there was like a link
there between because
l ron hubbard and aleister crowley knew
each other yeah right so
and scientology is like very influenced
by that type of
those occult b uh beliefs so we did talk
about a little bit on that but
ma i don't know maybe we should show you
like certain things about scientology
okay first of all let me before i go on
to this i'm [ __ ] up all right
yeah obviously elrond hubbard
actually was actually a pretty cool guy
um all of the original cultists liked
him he was
he was good to them a lot of the bad
things that happened in scientology
was later that was david under the
command of david miscavige yeah
miscavige is like a [ __ ] devil
it's very different all right um
from the occult aspect and i elrond
hubbard
was really trying to figure out the
occult and mind powers and how
basically he was trying to make jedi
that's what they're talking about
which i wish that's what they're talking
about i don't think that's good i think
it
was
a decent attempt but
i mean he's working with he's not he's
not he's starting from zero he's not
working with him i mean i wish i could
blow people's heads up from far away
but believe me i tried it doesn't work
i'm trying to
try to evoke mental powers from people
precognition
psychic abilities telekinesis
there's something to it you know having
been involved in portuguese
and poultry guys stuff [ __ ] drunk
portuguese poltergeists
haven't seen poltergeist and having
dreamt true and had out-of-body
experiences like near-death experiences
and stuff
there's there's something to it it's
just that i'm not i'm not convinced his
method actually works
no no no but i don't know everything
about the methods
but if it did work there should be a
bunch of [ __ ] jedi running around
and scientology doesn't have any jedi
they have tom cruise
but i ain't gonna call tom cruise the
jedi not to like see him move something
with his mom although he would love it
if you did
although i do respect him i'm a jedifi
real i'm a jedi
although i do respect tom cruise
especially as an actor he does do all
those stunts himself he can ride
motorcycles he can do cool [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know he does a lot more than
your average actor
yeah but he's not in a jedi obviously
and another thing is is that tom cruise
got the best
scientology can offer so that's the best
case scenario right there
that's what i mean they would they just
kissed his ass the whole time they
weren't gonna treat him like they
treated like the rest of the police i
don't see any evidence of tom cruise
having [ __ ] psychic abilities
you know what i mean can we put that on
a shirt i don't see any evidence of tom
cruise having any
sounds [ __ ] crazy that sounds crazy
but it's not crazy
it's not [ __ ] crazy when you
understand what scientology is and what
it's about now
you know what i mean i i he he has
evidence of a sk of a skilled man
there's no evidence of [ __ ] jedi type
[ __ ]
you know what i mean he can't levitate
well here's the thing not [ __ ] moving
objects with his mind i get
like elrond fish lips hubbard as i like
to call it
ron fish livestock he was like a
marketing genius because he's basically
like okay well i love all this occult
[ __ ] like i love what you're doing with
you know this alistair crowley thing
where like you have to pay for like
levels of it's called
wizardry or whatever [ __ ] a
wizard right right like that
[ __ ] i love
that but like nowadays everyone's all
about the science so maybe we can like
combine those two things so i'm talking
about like
the science of like psychiatry which i
hate
and also like elrond hubbard did and
also the occult [ __ ] maybe i can combine
that
yeah and market that to idiots yeah
and it worked they didn't want to market
it to idiots he wanted to market it to
something called wales which is rich
people that have lots and lots of
rich idiots yeah well it was
it worked it was like mrs it was the
baggages it was
bilbo baggins and his wife whenever you
see who these whales are
they're nerdy little larpers yeah in
their [ __ ] 70s that have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of money
and if you pay clearly more money than
cents just paying attention to them to
make them feel
special and these big events and they'll
they'll fork that money over
even my broke ass wouldn't fall for that
stuff come on now the [ __ ] dead
giveaway is is that if you show up on
the doorstep
doorstep of [ __ ] scientology without
a pot to piss in and you're broke
they're not gonna [ __ ] help you
they're not gonna that's what i mean
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
[ __ ] put you in the sea organ and
slave your ass
exactly and [ __ ] make you work for
them for nothing that's what they'll
really do
yep yeah just in case
that's a dead giveaway right there just
in case anyone's thinking about joining
a cult i know no one is but
just just don't do it don't do it
especially not scientology for christ's
sake
tina's saying yes do the occult side of
scientology we talked about it sophie
said that we talked a little bit about
it on the
jack parsons show too yeah which we did
yeah because there was like a whole
intersection of like all those people
that were hanging out together like back
in the day
yeah that we're all into that kind of
occult [ __ ]
jonathan oracle says john travolta
thinks he's a jedi now what it is is
that
john travolta is doing the scientology
equivalent of praying the gay away
that's what he's doing that's why john
travolta is gay as [ __ ]
sorry that's what i heard and uh and
like i said i have a sort
like my aunt used to do facials on him
because he used to he has a house in
port orange he used to
back in the day he with that airplane
hanger and everything
and uh my aunt used to own a salon
that had like a lot of celebrities come
in and they would get like [ __ ]
facials and haircuts come in there all
the time tom can't keep a woman he's no
jedi no of course not
now tom you to to be tom
to be tom's woman tom cruise's woman you
got to go through a [ __ ] process you
have to go through an audition process
yeah you do you have to audition you
have to audition to be
to be his woman well i feel like he has
to get approval from other people as
well right
because he's if he can't just like go
out and pick his own girlfriend like a
normal person
victor garcia says tom cruise enjoys the
company of men
that's been a [ __ ] theory for a long
time but i'm telling you what happens
this is the deal
what was that tom cruise movie where he
dr he was dressed in his underwear
risky business did ferris building he
wasn't even in that i don't know that
[ __ ] that was matthew broderick what
happened was is back in the day there
was a movie called risky business where
tom [ __ ]
sync lip syncs to a song he's about what
20 maybe
it was old time rock and roll old time
rocker he's probably 18 19 20 run
he's dancing around in a dress shirt
with [ __ ] glasses
in his underwear and socks dancing and
every gay [ __ ] hit the [ __ ]
roof
when they saw that scene so then they
adopted
tom cruise as gay tom cruise was adopted
gay
he was not gay himself he's an honorary
gay men
adopted him and then from here on out
into every gay bar there's all these
[ __ ] pictures of tom cruise
dancing in his [ __ ] underwear that
was bag of the day all right
or pictures of him from top gun because
because i feel like top
gun was like gay peak gay
gay gay well i mean there was there's a
lot of competition because like commando
yeah is also in the mix i'm just like
tomato is very gay it is like 80s movies
80s accents action movies and [ __ ]
and if you have gay friends they will
confirm all this [ __ ] i had gay friends
if i could tell you
that who they were [ __ ] into back
then and that's what it was all right
but tom himself was not gay tom was
straight
thomas straight now
did tom get [ __ ] casting couch did he
get couched
back in the day by the casting crew
probably probably i feel like i can't
say that i feel like everybody did but
that doesn't make you gay though
that's just some [ __ ] that happened to
you
trading ass to other men to get a
multi-million dollar gig
kind of like male prostitution
um it would not surprise me i have no
evidence
but the culture of the hollywood culture
of the day
if you were going to get a multi-million
dollar [ __ ] part and you're a young
dude like tom cruise
you're gonna give up the ass well here's
the thing now
let's let's go back and we'll have a
hypothetical situation
hypothetically back when tom yeah was
that you we're young and pretty and look
kind of like yo rick springfield
yeah yeah with your feathered hair yeah
um
because i've seen the pictures yeah you
get pictures to prove
i do you got pictures to practice you
had gone to hollywood like say you
wanted to be a big like movie singer
yeah
and some like lecherous creepy old [ __ ]
was kind of like hey i'll give you a
multi-million dollar
movie contract if you give up the booty
hole yeah
would you have done it no no because are
you sure
i know let's say it was 18 19 years old
no i know so
because that's why i didn't become an
actor because that [ __ ] happened
because i know because i knew that that
[ __ ] because you knew that [ __ ] was that
yeah you're like no but i don't want any
part of that i knew that's how that [ __ ]
i'm gonna keep my butthole virgin
[Laughter]
you know i i did [ __ ] drama school
with [ __ ] people that actually made
it like [ __ ]
you know marilyn rice cub and [ __ ]
parker posey you know those are friends
of mine
and uh no most guys that did well in
highest in
in in in the early parts of high school
drama
who could have [ __ ] carried whole
roles and did musicals and [ __ ]
most of them didn't go on to have a
career most of the guys didn't
because you knew back then
you're a hooker that's what they're
[ __ ] doing well the thing about it is
that every it's not just men it's women
too
women too yeah you're going to everybody
you can be a hooker yeah
because what are you going to do wait
tables what are you gonna do
you know what i mean you don't you don't
have a sk you don't have an
irreplaceable skill
i mean that's the shitty thing is that
so many people like i never really i
never wanted to be an actor or anything
because i'm kind of like an introvert
and i don't really like pretending to be
other people i'm not good at that
but i can see how if that's your [ __ ]
dream man and you want to be a [ __ ]
movie star
i can see how you go out to la you wait
tables for a few years you get really
disillusioned i can
see how that happens where you just be
like look i'll just do anything
i can see how that happens well it's
always the leads like the leading women
and leading men when they're yoga and
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] casting couch
yeah ugly people don't go through that
[ __ ] yeah i mean they can make it but
they can make it by
just talent nobody wants to [ __ ] because
i'm a character yeah they're character
actors nobody wants to [ __ ] them they
hire me see i could probably be an actor
now now that i'm old because it's like
nobody can do it now no one's going to
[ __ ] with me now because i'm like i'm
almost 50 and like exactly
no one's going to [ __ ] put a 17 year
old in front of you right exactly
yeah so it's like i don't have to worry
about it anymore that's one of the other
nights
[Laughter]
and you know what i mean they're [ __ ]
back in those days they didn't have any
[ __ ] limits all the [ __ ] child
stars and [ __ ]
what's it corey feldman and everything
came with all this that's all true
well look at damn drew barrymore man she
was like all [ __ ] partying when she
was [ __ ] 12 or something yeah even
before that maybe
before that even who was the girl that
did [ __ ]
tatum o'neill tatum o'neill yeah well
she was kind of a wild child
yeah she did sex parties at 11 i think
yeah
they're like it was a different time
back and it would not surprise me if you
know
you had [ __ ] who's that [ __ ]
natalie portman and [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
because she showed up in the [ __ ]
damn the professional and everything
it would not surprise me if [ __ ] they
ran through that girl too i mean
they're bad they're bad well because
they know that they have something that
other people
want and will do pretty much anything to
get it so anytime you have it's not just
acting it's not anything it's like any
time you have a situation like that
and it's like dealing with the mafia
you're gonna get that type of abusive
behavior because that's just how because
people are the worst
it's like dealing with the mafia people
are the worst and even the [ __ ]
parents and [ __ ] of these kids knew the
deal
because the parents don't have a pot to
piss in well they're like hey this kid
could be a millionaire yeah
you're gonna be we could be millionaires
kid go ahead and go [ __ ] let him
stick a dick in it yeah it's all right
it'll be over in a little while yeah
right yeah
not like it'll cause you like lasting
trauma or anything no what a [ __ ]
no i was like [ __ ] acting i joined the
army
i didn't want to [ __ ] pretend to have
an adventurous i want to [ __ ] have
them
yeah man the war kicked off i went right
to it yeah i got you
they made movies about [ __ ]
like me see
i feel like i feel like in 20 years
people gonna make your bio pick
tom the baby i ain't gonna tell a full
story until i'm almost on my death bed
really yeah i'll tell the full story
wait do i know the full story is it
like well i was gonna say so i didn't
know if there was other [ __ ] you were
like keeping from it right now okay
so it's not that bad i'm sorry yeah
sophie says it's predatory gatekeeper
yeah it was predatory gatekeeper
behavior yeah sanders said man i was
sexually harassed for the first time in
my life last weekend i'm jenny's age
never too old for that
no it still happens it still happens um
nowadays like i said not so much
nowadays because i don't
work anymore or i don't like go out of
the house that much anymore
but for sure a couple years ago when i
was working
yeah that happened as well yeah yeah
they could talk about tom cruise being
an honorary bottom and [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] i don't think tom cruise is
gay
i don't know if anybody got to him but
they might have got to him
and the reason why i said they might
have got to him
is because when you go to scientology
they make you confess all your sins and
they record all that [ __ ]
yeah because they have dirt on you later
on yeah blackmail material you confess
all your sins on a damn
primitive lie detector machine and then
they record all that [ __ ] so later on if
you betray the church they release
all that information so he the reason
why he hasn't left the church
possibly is because maybe he told them
some [ __ ] that they don't want out that
he doesn't want out although i feel like
nowadays
unless you were like a pedophile i feel
like
you know oh tom cruise is gay when he's
like yeah and i don't think anyone would
care
i don't think he's gay same with it well
no i'm just saying that for an example
and
honestly john travolta if that's the
only dirt they have on him
yeah if they came out and said john
travolta is gay everyone's like yeah
obviously
i don't think well i don't think anyone
would care john's
it's not like it's not like back in the
old days when that was like a big stigma
it's like now everyone's like yeah and
who cares
like i said unless you're like a
pedophile or a serial killer or
something like that i can't really think
of that much that would
make everybody just like turn against
you travalta is gay
i yes like i said i know from a family
member that yeah
i mean she thought that he was but and
she knew him even some pretty spiteful
people who were involved in the [ __ ]
church of scientology they say that no
tom cruise is not gay tom cruise is very
easy yeah i don't think i don't think
you you stay straight
but travolta yeah yeah right um
but you know like i said i don't i don't
want to out people if they don't want to
come out but i'm just saying that like
nowadays that's not
like the stigma that it used to be like
by a long stretch
i just wave i i just can't wait till
zuckerberg comes out
that [ __ ] no one will care about
that either
come out of the closet bro like i said
no one will care why are you denying
your [ __ ] that's not something that
people care about anymore
like i said i can't really think of
anything that would make people
like i said unless you're a pedophile
like if you're a pedophile that everyone
will like get mad
sure zack's in the crowd hey zach man
tell me man is mark zuckerberg
gay if you think he's gay gonna put in
the comments i'm sure zach is probably
not second
oh yeah he's gay like all the gay men
are getting together at the gay man
meeting and like talking about who's gay
and who's not
yeah in your mind it's like the gay
alliance
it's the gay alliance yeah we all get
together on zoom and like we have this
big [ __ ] meeting every month like
talking about who's gay
because they all know each other but yes
holy [ __ ] all right so where was i okay
so
ken bianchi like i said was faking being
a psychologist he had an office and
everything and he had like a fake degree
another thing that he did was that
he had like this really bad cough right
and his
girlfriend said hey maybe you want to go
to a doctor for that
he went to the doctor apparently nothing
serious was wrong however
he told his girlfriend that he had lung
cancer
and that he had to like go through all
these [ __ ] like chemotherapy and
radiation and stuff
and she got really upset about it
because she thought he was telling the
truth
and he used that as an excuse like i
guess to manipulate her and also to like
get out of going to work because he's
like oh the radiation i just i feel so
weak today i can't go to work he like
did that kind of [ __ ] he didn't have
lung cancer
look at this [ __ ] this dude is like he's
terrible lung cancer to get out of going
to work
that's some [ __ ] pretty much and to get
sympathy from his girlfriend yeah
like i said he was a pathological liar
yeah so he just like lied about [ __ ]
you out to like yeah i have lung cancer
what the [ __ ] man the hell's wrong with
this dude so
now the interesting thing about this is
that around this time that he was faking
lung cancer
which is a sense i never thought that i
would say um
the police did actually go to his
apartment
in not necessarily investigating but in
relation to the hillside strangler
murders
because one of the victims as i
mentioned was
lived in the same building as him so
they actually went to his house like
asking him if he knew anything about the
murder and the police
even though they interviewed him they
had it on record and everything like
that but they didn't consider him a
suspect because he didn't seem
suspicious
at the time so his his name was
in their paperwork of the case because
he lived in the same building as one of
the victims
however he was not considered a suspect
so
there you go another thing that's very
interesting like i said that ken was
like a cop groupie
he had the cajon i don't want to say he
had the cojones of the balls or anything
like that because that makes him sound
like a badass and i want to do that
he went to the lapd and they had that
program where you could do like civilian
ride-alongs
because like oh neat we can like ride
along with the cops and everything he
totally [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
he went and rode along with the cops and
he
like kept talking about the they didn't
wouldn't take him to like the hillside
strangler sites or anything
because he said something like um oh are
we gonna go to like the hillside
strangler like where they found the
bodies or anything the cops like no no
it's like i don't have anything to do
with that case or whatever and he's like
oh that's good because that'd probably
be like too messed up i don't want to
see that [ __ ]
but he was like fishing for information
is what he was doing right so he did
like a bunch of ride alongs with the
[ __ ] cops
yeah and they were looking for him and
he was right there he was curious
like i said i'm not blaming the cops in
this situation it's the 70s
they didn't have dna they didn't it's
like you don't know it's easy to say
like in hindsight
obviously this dude was the killer
because they know now
but back then he was just some dude that
was like riding along with the cops he
didn't seem suspicious they're like he
didn't seem
weird in any way you know what i'm
saying he wasn't even a suspect when
they like investigated him about the uh
the girl that was killed in his building
now at this point like ken and his wife
were having or his
girlfriend wasn't really his wife but um
they were having like some kind of
problems
and so they would kind of like break up
get back together break up
get back together they had like a baby
son his name was shawn
and basically they were like okay well
things are okay for a while but then
like they got kind of like shitty again
she was like he was just like
blowing all his money it's like you know
we had a baby i thought he would be more
responsible and
that he would like kind of step up to
the plate and that didn't really happen
so finally she's like [ __ ] this i'm out
of here so she moved back to
where her parents and her friends lived
which was bellingham
washington which if you'll remember is
where ken moved later on
and killed two more girls and got a
stupid ass caught so
she moved away ken was obviously very
upset because oh
the those treacherous women have
betrayed me once again because of course
it was not his fault
uh so she took off now
basically so she goes there and he
like kept writing to her he kept writing
to her and finally she was like okay
[ __ ] just
fine we'll get back together but you
have to move up here because i'm not
moving back to la because i don't like
that place
so at this stage so the cops in la
they have this photo of bianchi who at
this point they're pretty sure
that he is at least one of the hillside
stranglers because like i said the cops
even from very early
knew that it was probably more than one
person working as a team
so they release a photo of him to the
media
one of the first calls they get is from
this dude named david wood he was a
lawyer
now david wood says to the cops um hey
i was instrumental in there were these
two girls they were teenagers
and they were their names were becky
spears and sabra hannan
they were working for ken bianchi and
his cousin
angelo buono they these two guys were
basically forcing these two teenage
girls to be a prostitute they were
pimping them out is what they were doing
and they were keeping them essentially
prisoner
is what they were doing so what ended up
happening was one of the girls becky had
escaped
and knew this lawyer and like told him
about it and then they were actually
able to get the other girl out
so david wood like called the cops and
said hey these two dudes were like pimps
they were working together maybe you
want to like look into that because they
were like
basically physically beating the girls
up like if they didn't do what they
wanted
so um so they at this point they go
to talk to angelo buono because his name
keeps coming up
uh in relation to ken bianchi like these
two dudes were like pimping these two
girls out
so let's talk a little bit about angelo
buono because at this point
because his name keeps coming up the
cops are like well this must be
the other hillside strangler because
they knew it was at least two dudes
so they go to talk to this dude now
angelo buono as i mentioned earlier
not an attractive man not i don't know
like a lot of the [ __ ] about him is like
says he's ugly
which he kind of is ugly but i feel like
uh i don't know i feel like when you're
saying ugly you're like elephant man
ugly he's not that bad
it's just that like i said he looks like
the quintessential
guido kinda he had like the [ __ ] you
know what i mean
he was like an older dude at the time
and
honestly from all accounts he was a
giant giant douche nozzle
you know what i'm saying like even worse
than ken biake which is pretty bad
worse than douche canoe um yeah there's
levels of the [ __ ] there's like a you
know you got you douche canoe you got
your good douche nozzle you got your
douche barrel
[Laughter]
there's a whole there's a whole spectrum
of douchiness
[Laughter]
i have used many many especially when
i'm driving i feel like i come up with
all these fun i didn't know about all
that
i didn't know that there was well now
you do there's an auto
there's like an autistic spectrum but
you spectrum
[Laughter]
that's that's what this is so yeah
angelo bono like i said he was much
older than ken bianchi who was his
cousin
so he's this douche and as we mentioned
earlier when we were talking about
sylvester stallone this dude also likes
to be called the italian stalin because
inexplicably
even though he was a giant gaping anus
and not really all that good looking
um he did seem to be popular at least
with teenage girls
which [ __ ] i don't know how much that
says about your attractiveness but okay
[ __ ] was hung like a chipmunk i
imagine he probably was like no one has
ever mentioned that yeah
i feel like his whole personality is
like over compensation
sure i i do kind of feel like that now i
will say
that he was married a bunch of times uh
he had a bunch of kids
i think eight like by different women so
he like passed his jeans on you guys
yeah there's a whole tribe of them out
there like [ __ ] jenga's khan which
hopefully
like his kids turned out okay i'm sure
they changed their names because i
[ __ ] would
um now all of his kids sadly he at least
physically abused them and some of them
including one of his 14 year old
stepdaughters
he also sexually abused to quote unquote
break her in
damn breaking her in like a pair of
shoes
yeah damn so like i said we're not
talking about like a real quality that's
a stepdaughter huh
yeah we're not talking about a real
quality human being yeah now he is also
from rochester
new york just as ken bianchi was now he
was born in 1934.
now he ended up moving to glendale
california when he was only
five with his mom and his sister now
again i don't think he had it like he
had a dad obviously but they got
divorced like when he was
a kid so the mom moved there she worked
in a shoe factory
now um angelo buono was also brought up
catholic kind of like how ken was sort
of half acidly
but it didn't really seem to do him any
good or bad or anything
else again he seemed like
angelo bono probably more than ken
bianchi ken bianchi seemed like
i don't know if sociopath would be the
right word ken bianchi just seemed like
a pathological liar just like pat
you know he's just like superficially
charming and [ __ ] like that like they
say about sociopaths
but it seems like angela buono even from
a very early age
was just like a sexual sadist like he
just seemed like a [ __ ] from like when
he was a kid he was just like a terrible
terrible
person i gotta say something though
what's that again
ezio said that uh steven seagal is a
fascinating heterosexual
[Laughter]
is a fascinating heterosexual he sure is
damn man you can't say things like that
about steven seagal he might like
sit in a chair and like look at you i
just want to say
like squint at you kind of and then like
he'll kind of threaten you but he's not
going to be able to get up because he's
too bad
i just want to say there's many men in
this world but none of them are like me
i'm going to have an entire swimming
pool filled with my
fill of my energy drink it's an asian
experience yeah
that's my experience asian women in my
space
in my swimming pool i'll drink it all
imagine that [ __ ] it's so gross
yeah that [ __ ] commercial we talked
about that on the stephen segal show
he was hamming it up in the commercial
he knew it was [ __ ] corny but there's
something about that [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i wonder if that girl that they hired to
be in the commercial was like oh god
just gave me a [ __ ] check i'm going
home
that was just something i i just need a
[ __ ] bleach shower
she's like yeah baby i'll be in here in
a minute
don't rush yeah i'll be over here the
asian experience let me have a drink of
that
i actually had a guy who still had a can
of asian experience
uh he made a whole vid made a whole
youtube well on cinema massacre
yes they were talking about they did
like a whole stephen seagal they were
talking about like steven seagal movies
and that one guy that's on i can't
remember what his name is but that one
guy that's on there sometimes
yeah he still had one because he has a
huge he has like a weird obsession with
steven seagal like in a weird ironic way
so he has like all these action figures
and all his movies and stuff and he had
an
unopened can of asian experience and he
drank it
on that show he said it was okay yeah
not great though
but it was 10 years out of date yeah it
was really old he said it's really old
yeah
i just i thought that was kind of neat
that he like cracked it open on that
particular show
that was a really entertaining channel
would re-release that i wouldn't mind
i'd buy a whole case of that [ __ ] i bet
you would that seems like something
drink it on the show now i'm gonna have
to get some like on anybody get you some
for christmas let's get a little chinese
get a little black chinese silk shirt
wear a little bruce lee outfit [ __ ]
yeah wear a yellow jumpsuit paint
paint like a v-shaped hairline right
here
i'm gonna put glasses on a little goatee
haven't put a big fat suit
faster you need a fat too it's going to
drink my asian experience
you have to get you well you have to get
like really close to the camera and just
squint at it
yeah you have to get like way closer
than you are right yeah yeah [ __ ]
because we have to get music we can't
well yeah we can't like
have we can't film you from that angle
we have to film you just from your face
because
he doesn't want anybody seeing like how
tubby he is
so they have to like close up on his
face so he's just like has a face
he's looking intimidating there's
something that i learned is that like
after the
third or fourth stephen seagal movie
that came out
they were all they were all sabotaged on
purpose
by [ __ ] producers and [ __ ] studios
thank you very much for the asian
experience can ebay search
yeah i didn't know i didn't know this
we're getting off topic
but what else is part of this show
steven seagal's movies were [ __ ]
sabotaged by hollywood people that's how
much they hated that dude
that's why they were so bad is is that
his story and he's sticking to it
no other people no people that were
arrested
in the production said that they did
they went out of their way to sabotage
those movies in edit
and to do all kinds of [ __ ] to make them
as shitty as possible
i could see because they were trying to
do that they were trying to drive him
out of hollywood just to be funny they
[ __ ] couldn't stand him they're
trying to drive him out of hollywood
like i said he does seem like a giant
phone they couldn't they couldn't stand
him
they couldn't stand so i would i would
totally do that if i was editing one of
his movies and he was like
being steven seagal i'd be like yeah
they had to wait till you see this movie
[ __ ] yeah one of the
directors that was doing one of his
movies [ __ ] would like
[ __ ] cut out entire [ __ ] scenes
that they did
shoot but it just cut them out to make
to make the movie not have any
continuity
someone was like what the [ __ ] am i
watching cut this one out this one out
the movie won't make any sense they were
doing this [ __ ] on purpose
victor said we should make a new t-shirt
that says we're getting off topic
yeah that's true
okay well i'm going to go after you but
i'm going to like see because i'm
getting to that point
also both of our kids are you then
you're going to make me sit there and
[ __ ]
at the con or fly the [ __ ] enterprise
yeah
what you can't do it you can do it all
right so
like i said angelo bono giant [ __ ]
dick smack so he's basically like
he was um i guess what they would
nowadays call a sex
addict or he thought he was anyway
um he basically straight up hated women
whereas ken bianchi had more of like a
madonna [ __ ] thing where it's like
sometimes
he'd quote unquote put [ __ ] on the
pedestal and other times like then he
would like denigrate women that didn't
live up to his unrealistic standards
angela bono it seemed like just hated
women just all around
like for no reason particularly i guess
um reportedly
he would call his mom a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
to her face um but
much like ken bianchi was also kind of
like
had a weird like codependent
relationship with her
this is like very strange to me it's
like i don't really understand like
though because i'm not a dude
and i don't understand like the whole
weird like dude mom dynamic it just
seems very norman bates but that does
seem to be what was going on in these
two dudes cases it just manifested
itself in slightly different ways
so basically like so he was like really
like
emotionally dependent on his mom but
also hated her and i guess
well i guess that kind of explains but
he hated her because he was emotionally
dependent on her i'm guessing that's
how that shook out so uh
his mom died in 1978 um
now even when angelo was
a teenager like i'm talking like 13 14
years old
he would i don't know if this is true or
not but he did actually tell like his
friends in school and stuff like that
that oh yeah i totally like
raped these girls like so he like told
other people that and he was like proud
of it
like i said i don't know if that really
happened or not but he did tell other
people that he was like raping girls
when he was 14.
now he did um get sent to
he got in trouble when he was a teenager
for a grand theft auto
and he got sent to like a boys school or
whatever
now another thing too was that from a
very early age this is super [ __ ] up
you guys
from a very early age one of his big
heroes
and he admitted this like outright when
he was a kid
was this dude named carol chesman who
was a serial rapist
so that was like his hero because he
thought that
he really liked the way carol chessman a
serial rapist
just kind of like uh took whatever he
wanted whenever he wanted it and like
that was
his hero so you know this is this is the
kind of kid that we're talking about
carol chessman in case you didn't know
what he would do
was that he would go up to um
it was sort of like the zodiac and a
little he would go to cars where like
you know people were making out like in
their cars
and he would uh draw a gun on him and
then he would
um he would pretend to be a cop and he
would um then show them a gun and then
take the girl into his own car and rape
the girl
that's that was like his mo and
angelo buono just thought that was the
[ __ ] he thought that was coolest thing
ever and
uh fun fact that was where angelo buono
got the idea of pretending to be a cop
which they did on many of their later
escapades as the hillside stranglers
so angelo uh he got a girl pregnant
uh in high school in 1955
he married her but left her less than a
week later
so she had the baby in 1956 his name was
michael
obviously this should come in as no
surprise but angela wouldn't give her
any
child support or anything like that and
uh also when the kid was born he was in
jail again
for car theft so he had another son
in 1956 he married the mom in 1957
and they had a bunch of kids uh together
like he had uh there was one named peter
in 1957
danny 1958 louis in 1916 grace and i
decided so this kid
so this guy's has like a lot of kids now
mary the wife uh she
finally filed for divorce uh in 1964.
uh she's basically like this dude is
just like a [ __ ] nightmare
he's [ __ ] raped her you know
repeatedly called her a [ __ ] like pretty
much every day
it was just like uh he would beat her up
and make the kids watch
all this other kind of [ __ ] so it was
terrible uh he didn't have to pay any
child support mary took off but she had
to go on welfare because she had a bunch
of kids and he wouldn't help her so you
know
um she actually just
i guess because she was in terrible like
financial straights she actually did
consider like getting back together with
him for a time
but i guess when she went to talk to him
he handcuffed her put a gun in her
stomach and threatened to shoot her
so she was like yeah never mind and then
she took off and never spoke to him
again
thankfully so then he starts this is
1965.
so then he moves in with this younger
woman who was 25 years old her name was
uh
nanette campina now he had two more kids
with her
one named tony in 1967 one named sam in
1969
she was also horribly abused by him like
every other woman that came in his orbit
was
um she only stayed with him because she
was afraid that he would kill her
if she left which he told her many times
that he would
now the only reason that she finally
left
was that he started raping as i
mentioned earlier her 14 year old
daughter saying that she needed to be
broken so finally the mom was like okay
that's
you know you can beat me up that's one
thing but 14 year old girl yeah [ __ ]
that i'm out of here
so she took the [ __ ] off went to another
state
hopefully she's okay nowadays now uh
he married another girl in 1972 but for
some reason i don't know why he married
her exactly because like they never
lived together they never didn't you
know what i mean so they they just live
severally i don't know
so now in 1975 as i said now this was
when
ken finally moved to la angelo
despite being he wasn't stupid but
he wasn't real bright either
but he was really really good at this
one very specific thing which was auto
upholstery
like which they had found out when he
was you know working for
like a mechanic or whatever so he was so
good at this
that he actually was able to open his
own shop doing it
and his shop actually had a really good
reputation like he was he did like limos
he worked on one of frank sinatra's cars
he did like all this kind of [ __ ] so he
had like a really good reputation around
la being a really good auto upholsterer
so so he had this place um
on east colorado street that was like
his residence but it was also like his
shop
and he didn't have any employees so he
could basically do whatever he wanted in
this [ __ ] place
now as i said earlier even though this
dude was like
a [ __ ] walking nightmare clearly um
teenage girls for some reason like
[ __ ] loved him
i don't know if it was because
teenage girls are kind of like naive and
they're just like oh they love the bad
boy and everything like that so maybe
they kind of like
saw that in him because he was very like
kind of arrogant and cocky and
everything and they were kind of
into it and he seemed to have
i don't know it was just weird the way
they were like attracted to him
so he really didn't have any problem
like getting laid or anything like that
because he always had like all these
women like hanging around little girls
really
um but yeah it was just like really
[ __ ] up
so kenny shows up you know ken bianchi
shows up
around this time period and as i said he
kind of like
idolized angelo because like man look at
you angelo with your [ __ ] gold chains
and your
red silk underwear and all your teenage
jailbait girlfriends like hanging around
i could kind of get used to this you
know what i mean
so basically angelo told him
well you gotta this isn't the words they
use but this is something tom would say
you gotta lay down the pimp hands
you gotta unholster the pimp you gotta
unholster the peppers
and that [ __ ] better be 45 caliber
but i feel like that's kind of what
angela was telling to his younger
cousin you know he said things like you
can't let a [ __ ] get the upper hand he
would say [ __ ] like that
yeah like you got to put him in their
place yeah and ken was like yeah preach
it brother
they were kind of like they were two of
a kind and that's but actually that's
kind of like what that
uh one of the most famous books about
the
about the hillside strangler case is
called it's called two of a kind because
these two [ __ ]
they were clearly made for each other in
the worst possible way
two dudes that basically have no way
with women teaching uh
teaching each other how to fight but the
[ __ ] that thing is that angelo did kind
of have a way even though he was ugly as
[ __ ]
and even that like he had his [ __ ]
stupid hair and his like stupid [ __ ]
mustache or whatever stupid mouth yeah
he was just saying he was real and
honestly like
you could say like he didn't really have
any problem getting laid but i feel like
like a lot of his girlfriends were much
much much younger
and he probably targeted like a lot of
these types of dudes do they usually
target like
vulnerable women that are like really
young or really naive
or have been like abused in their life
like they have some kind of like shitty
situation happening at home and they
want to escape it or something they seem
to like hone in on those types of girls
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah so
uh at this stage like i said so ken's
shorter money and this was the point
where
angelo comes up it's like hey let's
start a prostitution business because
that's like what you [ __ ] do
so that was when they kind of i don't
know if they necessarily kidnapped these
two girls but they
for sure like lured them and they were
kind of like hey we're gonna do this
thing and they're like oh by the way
we're pimping you out um and basically
we'll beat the [ __ ] out of you and kill
you if you try to leave so
that was that whole thing um so they
kind of kept them prisoner
did you need to take a break uh i do
actually okay are you gonna be all right
yeah are there any commercials i need to
uh
um i don't actually i don't have any
pookie videos but you could
uh play the fe3 commercial and then you
could like talk about some [ __ ] but yeah
i gotta pee we'll be right back all
right we'll
play the commercial and then i'll come
back and i'll talk about steve segal
[ __ ] right you love true crime
i love true crime and i've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain and
volume 3 is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
ketty murders the carrie babies case
the frog boys the alcasar murders and
the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faceless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
all right we're back yeah we're talking
about steven seagal movies
steven seagal all right he really only
had
four good movies he had under siege one
and two
and he had hard to kill and he had that
other one where he was wearing that
[ __ ] silly ass beret
but in all movies [ __ ] he runs like a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] runs like a [ __ ] just
[ __ ] arms flapping
and i tell the story i've told this
story before
when i was in the army they played under
siege for us one time when i was up in
egypt
and the [ __ ] word on the street was
is that he really wasn't it was navy
seal
and i watched that movie right and i
kept looking at his arms
and i'm going like
a navy seal i don't see any condition in
there
and then later on i saw him [ __ ] run
and when i saw him [ __ ] run with them
chicken wings flapping
i knew i knew that [ __ ] had never been
in the service
because [ __ ] when you're in the
[ __ ] army or you're in the [ __ ]
navy especially navy seal
you know how to [ __ ] run and those
[ __ ] group runs and [ __ ] there's a
certain cadence and there's a certain
way to run
and that dude couldn't do it that dude
runs like a [ __ ] and he knows he runs
like a [ __ ]
here comes jenny well everybody's
noticed that he runs like a [ __ ] i mean
i feel like because we're not even the
first people that have noticed that he
runs like a dude that's never
run even a one quarter of a mile
that dude's never been on he runs like
not even like a human
it's like like i'm like what it that is
like the weirdest thing i've ever seen
yeah and i don't even like running but i
don't run like that yeah that dude's
never even run a quarter of a mile
like he doesn't have any like
coordination like i don't know if his
body and his limbs like don't
stephen seagal is an amazing not on the
same page steven seagal is an amazing
man
he's an amazing man who
basically bullshitted his way into
hollywood
amongst some real [ __ ] sharks like
like
arnold and [ __ ] carl and call
weathers and [ __ ] you know i mean dudes
that actually had
some physicality and had some training
behind him and
maybe even some military experience he
he lied his way into that group and
tried to be
and became an action star all on the all
on the [ __ ] basis of being
a fake martial artist well yeah some
people might say well wait a minute
he he was an akito master
well we talked about we talked about
that aikido is a fake martial art
well i don't know if it's something it's
a martial art but it's not
it's not like a fighting no it's not it
was
developed supposedly it was developed
by samurai who could throw up
or people who were fighting samurai and
could as a defense against swords
i went through you see this [ __ ] you
just [ __ ] laugh at it that's not the
way
it's it's not practical um
and he his martial artist that martial
arts are
full of [ __ ] this all came from a time
when we didn't really know what the
limitations of martial arts were
i remember you know i mean if i can we
weren't really sure about
bruce lee and what what was really
possible
we didn't really know much about what
was physically possible in terms of
martial arts this is even in the
military we really weren't really
sure until much later when mma came out
when [ __ ] mark when ultimate fighting
came out
that's when we first got a view of
[ __ ] what really worked and what
really
and what didn't work and you guys can
look up the history of that that
ultimate fighting man [ __ ]
when that first [ __ ] when that [ __ ]
first appeared we were like man where
are they
gonna kill each other there's no rules
it didn't really go down that way but
you saw a lot of these so-called martial
artists get their [ __ ] ass whipped
now it's good now yeah wow that was like
the big [ __ ] demystification yeah big
big justification of [ __ ] wushu
and [ __ ] throwing chee balls and [ __ ]
like on a street fighter
street fighter 2 video game yeah i can
just stand there and go like that i
think i'm sorry
i'm still getting wonderful i'm still
going to get my ass yeah
[Laughter]
now we have mma and you know with mma
that [ __ ]
that proved that showed the world what
works and what what
what doesn't work well at least in that
kind of like full contact fighting
yeah yeah and a [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you saw from bloodsport the
kumite and all that crap
[ __ ] you know what does that do today
[ __ ]
david dukes david dude david ducks i
call that [ __ ]
ducks okay ux yeah with his fake [ __ ]
special forces background and [ __ ]
most of the martial arts i grew up and
no i'm going to say all
of the martial arts that i grew up with
as a kid same with you if you're the
same age as me
all that [ __ ] was fake they had us going
they [ __ ] yeah and like i said are
not like [ __ ] on the whole and i
said this on the
on the um the [ __ ] show as well but
yeah it's not that it's like fake and
that it's not useful it's just not
useful for what they're saying that it
is
and i think that a lot of them say that
they have like like you said the [ __ ]
with the che
ball and all that kind of stuff like
that they almost like have magical
powers
yeah and obviously that's not true a lot
of that [ __ ] came from black belt
magazine
black belt magazine made [ __ ] yeah
they were a very large culprit yeah
yeah black belt magazine indication of
would put dudes on there that
supposedly could throw [ __ ] chee
balls and [ __ ] you know what i mean they
didn't [ __ ] talk about all this crazy
[ __ ] none of that [ __ ] was true
but you know it was another era you know
well you'd read some [ __ ] in a magazine
and you're like oh [ __ ] man
yeah and what's funny is that there are
whole
law enforcement units and military units
that were trained by
fake martial arts trainers guys that
totally
just pulled that [ __ ] back in the day
before we had the internet and even
nowadays like you can kind of like
they could kind of just make up their
whole backstory and everyone would
really check it
yeah yeah it was another era
you could just be like yeah man i did
this and i was like on the seal team and
i was this and that and the other thing
and no one would
be like oh okay that sounds impressive
and they just like let you do whatever
the [ __ ] you wanted it's crazy and
in a certain way i wish i could go back
to those days
so you could get a just so i could
enjoy them with the childlike wonder
that i had
back then they're like yeah you karate
chopped [ __ ] and they killed
like five of them
[Laughter]
got like the uber karate chop i can get
like five dudes the ones i just kind of
go doink and like they all [ __ ]
dropped it and what was funny is that
during this time that i'm watching these
[ __ ] clowns
i was i was the first in the 506 or i
was in [ __ ] 327th at 101st airborne
division
we were like cutting edge front line
[ __ ] airborne infantry all right
and we're looking at martial artists who
are total fakes
going yeah i think i can do that
it was kind of funny when you think
about it it is very funny very funny
like
the night yeah i need to learn how to do
that these dudes are [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
man that's
totally badass yeah i wish i could
[ __ ] stop
it's fake yeah i know but uh yeah so can
we hey how about you make me another
drink
okay that's my shit's empty oh man
you're right you're all right oh i'm
[ __ ] loaded i can't well yeah but i
can't believe you're still walking
around i'm walking
so well he walked out there okay we'll
see
all right so as i said now angelo and
ken were all up in their pimping
business they had two
um you know sex workers who were working
against their will so you know
that's fun and uh those two girls
escaped thankfully
and uh so these two jackals got really
upset about it
so they're like well they didn't have
their pimping income
anymore which resulted in ken
starting to default on the payments for
his used cadillac
and the car got repossessed so you know
good um all right so at this point
they're like okay well we need to find
some new girls to kidnap
for our pimping business now
they decided uh much like angelo's hero
that serial rapist i was mentioning
earlier carol chesman
they're like hey he pretended to be a
police officer let's do that [ __ ]
so it's very easy to get a fake police
badge and to basically go around telling
people
that you were a undercover cop so that's
basically what they started doing
now one of the women that they tried to
abduct but were unsuccessful
was this woman named catherine laurie
now they were actually going to kidnap
her and perhaps kill her
however they then found out that she was
the daughter
of famed actor peter laurie uh
famous for many things but probably most
famous for fritz lang's m
and uh so they found out that that's who
she was and they decided they were gonna
let her go
so they did she didn't find out until
later like who these [ __ ] were
thank you very much
now what ended up happening though this
was before they had killed anybody they
were still like trying to like kidnap
women for their
um pimping purposes
and one of the women that they were
talking
to was this woman that they knew named
deborah noble who was a
sex worker now she
supposedly had this list of all these
names with like all these johns on it
and she sold it to them now she had a
friend
and her friend was yolanda washington
who
if you remember correctly was ended up
being the hillside strangler's first
victim so basically what happened was
that this list i guess was fake or they
didn't think that it was good
information or whatever and they wanted
to
get back at deborah noble and kill her
but they couldn't find her
so they killed yolanda instead
which is basically like what started
their whole killing career
so all right so now that i've kind of
gone
into their backstory let's go back to
bellingham washington where as i said
ken bianchi has been arrested for the
murders of those two girls
now as i said him and angelo had killed
these 10 women
together like as a team he moved away to
bellingham washington because apparently
i guess
angelo was like yeah there's too much
heat on us we're gonna get caught or
whatever we need to knock this [ __ ] off
and from what i've heard the two of them
got into an argument about it
and um i don't know if angelo like told
ken to go away like [ __ ] off like back
to your girlfriend or whatever or if ken
went up his own volition i don't really
know
but he went off to bellingham and he
wasn't there for that long
before he's like okay well i gotta kill
somebody else so
as i said i don't know because most
people that talk about this case like
most experts and stuff
they posit that angelo buono was
probably the quote-unquote leader
because there's always one
like in these kind of teams of serial
killers just because he was older
he was um you know a lot more of like a
sexual sadist he was a lot more of a
sociopath he had been in prison before
for various other things not murder
but um you know other things and he had
kind of like a rapist mentality but he
also was in prison for like car theft
and various other things
whereas ken was more he was a [ __ ]
too but he was
maybe not as overtly murderous so
a lot of people speculate that had these
two not gotten together
then maybe ken wouldn't have killed
anybody but
the fact that after they broke up
i guess you could say ken was the one
to murder people again whereas angelo
did not
i don't know i think i think that might
cast like a little bit of a question on
that situation
so i don't really know like who was the
ringleader in this
thing you know what i'm saying like i
feel like all the movies that i've seen
about it it's kind of cast angelo as
more the leader because he was older but
i don't really know i don't i don't know
if angela would have killed anybody if
they hadn't gotten together
it was some weird kind of synergy when
they got together they just decided they
were going to
give each other confidence i guess it
was it was like some weird kind of
[ __ ] up
yeah i don't know it happens a lot with
those [ __ ]
duos like that yeah they started taking
each other into newer heights
i feel like that was definitely because
boy you could see it because the
earliest victims
like i said they were quote unquote just
strangled which like i said is bad
enough they were just like raped and
strangled
but then as the as it went on and like i
said it's a very brief time period that
they killed those 10 women it's only
like four months or something
but it really like it got to a point
where they were like
injecting girls with windex or like
trying to electrocute them or like they
were doing other things like adding on
you know what i mean like they just
strangling them or raping them like
wasn't enough
anymore they had to like add all these
[ __ ] extra flourishes i guess if you
want to say it like that
so okay so this is fun so ken is in
prison in jail like i said and they are
suspecting him with the murders like i
said they didn't have enough evidence at
first so they were holding him on like
all the
you know stolen property [ __ ] that they
found in his house
now when he was in jail
he's like using his brain it's like he
wasn't a dummy like he wasn't a genius
or anything like that but he was i think
his iq that they tested was like 116
which not super high but it's like
higher significantly higher than average
so he basically was like
the first thing he tried to pull was
that he told
his court-appointed lawyer that he was
suffering from
amnesia and that he didn't remember
committing any of the crimes so you know
i don't remember anything that was his
first
attempted defense um also they put him
under suicide watch because he acted
like he was all bummed out and
everything
now interestingly one of the first
social workers that came to talk to him
was really um i guess kind of fascinated
because they're like he seems like such
a mild-mannered nice guy
and couldn't really believe and his
girlfriend said the same thing his
employer said the same thing i couldn't
believe that such a nice guy
was a serial killer so i think from this
initial conversation
and ken knowing a little bit about
psychology
and also the fact that the movie sybil
had just aired
on television not too long before he was
interviewed he got the idea
that he was going to fake a multiple
personality disorder
so um he'd also seen three faces of eve
which was another multiple personality
thing so he thought that that was going
to be that's how he was going to get off
so that's what he decided he was going
to do
so he gets brought he talks to this dude
named dr watkins who apparently was an
expert at the time
in multiple personality disorder and
apparently he fooled this guy
what ken bianchi initially said
was that he was like this really nice
friendly person that everyone was used
to interacting with however
he had an alter ego called steve walker
that was the evil one and he was the one
that made
nice mild-mannered ken do all these
terrible things
and made him not remember it and if you
watch if you go on youtube there's like
a lot of
footage of like all of the uh police
interviews and [ __ ] like that where he's
trying to
establish himself as a do i look like
ken i'm steve he was like trying to do
that kind of [ __ ] right
um clearly not real
good but he did fool a lot of sight of
psychologists that came in to see him at
the time
just by pretending that he was somebody
else and that ken
poor innocent ken didn't remember what
his other personality was up to
you know personality disorders usually
women
not well no not always um it's a very
but it's very very very very rare
yeah very rare i thought most of the
confirmed cases were females
and it's not called multiple personality
disorder anymore it's called
dissociative associative symptoms
identity disorder that's what they call
it nowadays
and it's not as it's not quite as cut
and dried as it's always portrayed in
the movies
you know what i'm saying so i feel like
that's kind of what because sybil had
come out and that was kind of like in
the cultural zeitgeist with three faces
of eve all that kind of stuff
and because he knew a little bit about
psychology like i said he took like a
semester of that [ __ ] at [ __ ]
community college
so he knew enough to
say hey i'm gonna go that route maybe i
can get out of this
by saying that another personality did
and it wasn't me so he
knew enough to like try to fake it like
i said it wasn't stupid
um you know what i mean so he basically
said
but one thing that he did say like
during this whole like multiple
personality
shenanigans was he did implicate
his cousin angelo bono and he's like me
you know
steve my alter ego and angelo were the
ones that did this [ __ ] so the fact that
angelo buono's name came
up because cops were already suspecting
that he was the other hillside strangler
that was very very helpful
so um now another psychiatrist comes in
and noticed and some of the
investigators noticed too that while
they were
interviewing ken he kept like [ __ ] up
like when he was supposedly like in his
steve murderer persona like he would say
stuff like he would
refer to himself as he instead of i he
would do [ __ ] like that
so the cops are kind of like i you know
i i think he's faking i
i just really don't think this is legit
at all but the doctor was kind of like
no he legit has like a personality
disorder
so basically what one of the i love this
like
one of the main investigators like they
said well the first doctor that examined
him like seems to think that he really
does have like a multiple personality
disorder
the detective uh grogan said um
okay i got an idea the judge says to
bianchi okay i tell you what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna let ken off ken is
acquitted but steve gets the chair
let's see how he feels about that but
yeah so
as i said it was kind of uh you know
shitty because the
i think the detectives were like yeah
obviously he's faking the psychiatrists
weren't sure if he was faking or not
but they were happy that it implicated
angelo bono because like i said they
were looking at him as the second person
anyway
now they showed um while he was in jail
they showed a photo
of um the two guys to this dude
named marcus camden now he was a guy
that had seen judy miller who was the
second victim
he had seen her getting into a car like
on the night that she was murdered
now he recognized angelo buono
um he didn't recognize ken but he did
recognize one of them so that was like
another ding against them
now they also showed the photos to this
other this older woman
named bila stofer now she lived
um outside of she lived across the
street from lauren wagner
and she had actually seen lauren wagner
being put into the car like with these
two because she so she recognized the
car
and she immediately identified those two
guys like from a lineup
now so that was another thing that was
kind of like
you know so they bring in like i said
now they
a bunch of psychiatrists that came in
apparently fell
for his lame ass [ __ ] like of being like
a multiple personality right
but at this point the prosecution was
like okay well we're gonna bring in our
own [ __ ]
expert okay because you guys are
obviously falling for what is obviously
[ __ ]
so the detectives also noted
that the name of ken's uh alter ego
steve walker was the same name remember
went back when he was trying to like
fake being a psychologist and he had
like the fake office and everything
okay well steve walker was the name of
the doctor that he was
pretending to be when he was trying to
get like the fake diploma
and everything to be a psychologist so
they're like oh okay well that's just
where he took the name from so obviously
he's faking so they brought in his own
their own
uh expert now this dude was named dr
martin orn
and he was like a big like he was very
very well known like as a
expert in like hypnosis and [ __ ] like
that and he came in and he basically
like interviewed ken and he had like all
these [ __ ] traps
and one thing that he said was that you
know multiple personality disorder
your case is very unusual for only
having two personalities because
normally
um multiple personality disorder people
usually have at least three or more
at which case at which time uh ken
obliged by adding a third personality
which was it exactly what martin orton
expected him to do because he knew that
he was faking
he added a third personality called
billy at which point dr orton was like
yeah i thought so so that's uh kind of
how he
got him out of that one now
um so basically
there was like this big long thing where
he was trying to argue this kind of [ __ ]
like after he got called out
on that kind of crap um
and then after the doctor came in and
was like yeah i think he's faking there
was like a whole lot of argument about
that
but what they ended up doing was that
they decided they were gonna offer him
they said he's not insane they said he
competed to stand trial
so they're like what we're gonna do is
we're gonna offer him a deal
we're gonna say if you plead guilty to
the two
murders in washington and some
of the hillside murders in california
you will get life with the possibility
of parole you won't get the death
penalty
um and also you have to
testify against angelo buono and tell
everybody like what his part in the
murders was
so that was the deal that they offered
him now at first
he decided that he was gonna do it
um so at first he kind of like spills
the whole thing he's like yeah we
he told the whole thing about how they
pretend to be policemen like angela bono
had a [ __ ] fake police badge
um they said you know when the victims
were sex workers it was very easy
because we could just like purchase we
could just like pull up next to them
pretend we were cops and then say hey
you're under arrest or whatever
and um they actually did it with some of
the other women too like they would go
to the apartment like with um
one of the women like the girl that
lived next door to
ken they went to her house and he said
oh hey
i'm your neighbor i used to be your
neighbor i'm an undercover cop like your
car got broken into you need to like
come out and see to it
and that's like how they got her into
their car so they were doing that kind
of [ __ ] they were just like pretending
to be under cover crops
now so there was that whole thing now
they also found out too
that one of the main pieces of forensic
evidence that they found on the second
victim who was judy miller
was they found this really tiny piece of
like weird
white fluff like it was like stuck in
her eyelash or something like that and
they didn't know what it was or where it
was from
they found out later they were able to
match it to a piece of like
auto upholstery fabric that was in
angelo buono's
shop so that was another like big piece
of forensic evidence that the two of
them
were uh you know were kind of like
convicted on
so um also a lot of the places where
they dumped the bodies were kind of like
places that were nearby like where
angela lived or where his girlfriends
lived or whatever
um so ken kind of like spilled all the
conversation he told them about all the
[ __ ] he told them about trying to
electrocute that one girl
the one girl that they tried to like
[ __ ] gas they put a [ __ ]
one of the girls christina weckler who
was the girl that lived next door to
um to ken bianchi at one point they
basically
they put her like on like a bag over her
head
and like tied it like at the neck and
then they put like a pipe from the stove
because the stove wasn't installed all
the way and they put it like in there
and they were trying to like asphyxiate
her but it took like a really long
time for them to gas her damn so like i
said that was like they were like
building up to
they were experimenting like with
[ __ ] which is like [ __ ] up and they
just like kept doing it like [ __ ] oh
it's terrible but he did he admitted to
that
now the weird thing though is that as
soon as he like admitted all this [ __ ]
it almost seemed like he was like oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have said all that
because one
angelo is gonna be super pissed at me
and two
like i'm gonna get in [ __ ] trouble so
after that like he admitted all this
[ __ ] and then
he was basically like um
yeah well i don't remember like i think
angelo did it or he made me do it like
he came up with like all these [ __ ]
stories about him remember so even after
he'd like admitted all this [ __ ]
uh because like i said i think it got to
a point where he thought that
if he was responsible for angelo getting
put in jail
like he was gonna be in big [ __ ]
trouble you know what i mean like even
in prison like angelo would like [ __ ]
be able to [ __ ] kill him or some [ __ ]
like that so
it seems like he was trying to get out
of it but at that point he'd already
kind of admitted everything
now there was some kind of back and
forth about
because there wasn't enough physical
evidence to go after angelo
that they like the da was almost kind of
like i don't want to take the case
because i think we're going to lose this
because there's not enough physical
evidence and there was like this big
thing and like the investigators were
like freaking out because they're like
oh my god this dude is going to be like
still out on the street even though he's
clearly like murdered 10 women
um but in the end the judge was like
yeah [ __ ] this guy um
i don't care if you guys want to press
don't want to press charges we're going
to find somebody to press shirts on this
[ __ ] because we don't want him
running around
so it actually did so it was scary there
for a bit they thought they didn't have
enough to
hold him on but eventually they did um
actually convict him
so angelo gets arrested in october of
1979
and um you know they found his wallet it
had like the the
imprint of like the fake badge that he
always used which corroborated ken's
story
and there was all this other kind of
[ __ ] but so basically
they both end up now here's another
weird
thing to the case so spoiler alert it
ends up they both get i think ken got
six life sentences he's still alive
um but you know he's he's up for parole
he was
up for pearl in 2010 but it got denied
he's up for pearl again in 2025.
angelo buono happily died in prison of a
heart attack
natural causes in 2002. now listen to
this weird [ __ ] i wanted to add this
crazy
crazy coda to this case this just goes
to show sometimes women can be as crazy
as men
because ken after he was
in prison he got this girlfriend
named veronica compton now how he got
the girlfriend
veronica was supposedly she was writing
a play or a book or something like that
it was about a female serial killer and
it was called the mutilated cutter i
think which is a dumb title but whatever
so she initially wanted to interview ken
because she was like i need some insight
into my character so i want to talk to
like a real serial killer or whatever
so she goes to interview him and
apparently falls in love with this
stupid [ __ ]
she fell so much in love with him that
she wanted him to get out
so they came up with a plan that she was
gonna go back
you guys are not gonna believe this she
was gonna go back to bellingham
washington
where he had killed those two girls and
she was going to
strangle a girl and plant some semen
so that the cops would think that the
hillside strangler was still at large
and they would let ken out and
she actually went quite a way toward
that plan because okay
now ken gave her some jizz in a glove
now he was a non-secretor which back in
those days
meant that they couldn't determine your
blood type from your semen
you know what i mean so so it was okay
like if you left the same they couldn't
like identify you if you're a
non-secretor
so he gave her a bunch of semen in a
glove
and said go just go pick a random woman
and strangle her
in the way that we did it and so they'll
think that that dudes still run around
and they'll let me out
and she was gonna do it she got to a
point okay so she gets to a point
she goes to [ __ ] bellingham
she goes and like picks up this girl
like she tells her like i you know i
need you for something i don't even
remember how she [ __ ] did it it's
like she
she's like hey i need a ride to a motel
or something it's like hey come in and
have a drink with me like at this motel
and then she she has the this cord or
whatever and she comes at this girl like
trying to strangle her
but this other girl was like yeah no i'm
not having that and she like beat the
crap out of her
and then so then veronica was like okay
[ __ ] this i'm not like cut out for this
kind of [ __ ] but she liked
so she like took off now the weird thing
though is that veronica this crazy woman
then she tries to like leave and she
goes to like she gets in san francisco
airport
and then she draws attention to herself
by having some kind of like
episode like she has been kind of like
hysterical i don't know if she went like
full karen i don't know what she did
but she had like some thing that like
drew attention to her
and she also she also this is not the
brightest woman
she sends like a letter or a tape or
something like that to the cops in
bellingham
and says hey you guys arrested the wrong
man for those bellingham murders because
look at this
case that happened that i just did like
in [ __ ] bellingham where this girl
got so so obviously this strangler is
still running around
so they were like uh obviously [ __ ]
that was you
so she gets [ __ ] picked that's funny
because she's a [ __ ] idiot
so it's like she gets [ __ ] it did not
have a good grasp of police procedure
and that was normal for cops
this is a crazy woman this is and okay
and it gets crazier because
so they arrested her obviously because
she's [ __ ] insane
because they were able to match these
like hey this is the same [ __ ] that was
like freaking out at the [ __ ] san
francisco airport earlier
obviously this woman's not in the right
[ __ ] mind so
after this like ken was kind of like
okay well [ __ ] you [ __ ] that was like
my whole
cause he was only being nice to her to
you know get out of jail and like she
whiffed it so he was just kind of like
all right [ __ ] you i don't want anything
to do with you anymore
and then after that veronica decides
that
she's gonna take up with another serial
killer
douglas clark who i think we've talked
about on this show before actually i
think he was part of like one of those
serial killer couples
so she gets into him and
her and douglas clark make plans that
when he gets out which he's never going
to
that they're going to open a mortuary
so they can perform necrophilia on the
people
and the crazy thing is that veronica
this crazy woman
she was a defense witness at ken
bianchi's trial
and they said hey what's this we hear
about you and douglas clark opening up a
mortuary so you can [ __ ] dead bodies and
she didn't deny it
damn she was like yeah we're totally
gonna do that nobody's like
damn [ __ ] crazy
okay okay so that um
obviously that really didn't help ken
biakey's kids
his girlfriend not only was like gonna
strangle a girl to get her stupid
boyfriend out of jail
but was also gonna open up with her new
serial killer boyfriend
because she has a type clearly and
they're gonna open up more cherries they
affect dead bodies and she was
apparently like not
ashamed of like telling people about
that she didn't know any better
i guess about she thought that was a
thing i guess yeah that's crazy
also uh it should be noted that uh
douglas clarke who like i said i think
we've talked about on the show before i
think was on one of our killer couples
shows
um he was a big fan of like beheading
his
victims who were all women uh he also
sent veronica
valentine with a photo of a headless
female corpse on it so
that's nice you can see this is a
quality human being right here um
and i'm being sarcastic in case you
didn't know so
yeah there was that whole special [ __ ]
so like i said bianchi uh
actually eventually ended up getting his
[ __ ] together and saying okay i don't
have multiple personalities you got me
uh and he pleaded guilty to the two
washington murders and
five of the california the ones that
took place in california it's not all of
them but enough to like give him life
senses
now he didn't get the death penalty
because he agreed to testify against
angela buono um so angelo bono also got
sentenced to life in prison without
chance of parole they were in two
different prisons though
because i think bianchi was in walla
walla washington and
uh buono was in california somewhere
so uh bueno actually got convicted in
1983.
now the judge was basically like well
they said the death penalty was off the
table but
if i could convict you of death i
totally would because you were like a
piece of [ __ ]
i'm paraphrasing so but that's basically
what he said
so as i said earlier uh angelo buono
actually ended up dying of a heart
attack
in september of 2002 at prison and good
riddance
uh bianchi is still alive uh he actually
married a pen pal in 1989
uh i don't know if they're still married
or not i assume that they are he was up
for parole in 2010 but it was denied he
is up for
parole again in 2025 as i mentioned
earlier
bianchi is also a suspect in the
alphabet murders which took place in
rochester new york
although they don't know if he was
responsible for those or not and as i
mentioned earlier too there have been
several several movies about this case
if you would like to watch one of them
one of them is on youtube for free the
one from 1989
which has dennis farina in it playing
angelo buono and billy zane a very young
billy zane
as kenneth bianchi and also has um
richard krenna in it playing detective
grogan which i thought was but it's good
so it's a good movie and it seemed like
it was um from what i know of the case
it seemed pretty
accurate it even had the [ __ ] about the
german psychic in it which i thought was
very amazing
but uh yeah so there's some other ones
too i think c thomas howell was in one
of them
as well but yeah so uh i think that'll
do it for the case
anything else you want to talk about a
bad show we did it in three hours 18
minutes and i actually kind of like
talked the whole
about the topic most of the time yeah
it's because i was so loaded i couldn't
entertain
i couldn't i could interrupt so that's
the secret we have to get tom really
drunk
early and then i'm in i'm in the comment
section we're talking about steven
seagal movies too
charles manson even got married this is
the kind of [ __ ] what
there's only four good steven seagal
movies wait four
there's only four good ones that's a
little that's generous
under siege one okay i'll give you that
okay
[ __ ] hard to kill under siege two
oh yeah and then now for justice those
are really those
those are really the only only four i
like you know there may be
another one out there but i i don't know
it i don't know well he's made so many
you can't watch all
any anything beyond [ __ ] i mean you
could but anything beyond like 94 you
know i mean i don't really need to lose
any more iq points all the alcohol
is like probably doing a number on my iq
points so it's like i don't really need
to watch the secret
movies and like lose any more i think
anything beyond 1994 1995 you don't want
to [ __ ] with that
you know right right when he got to the
like the the fat it's all a close-up
with him
at you and then like he has body doubles
doing it just got more and more no
what the problem was is that it just got
more and more boring
the newer the okay here's the thing
they're all interchangeable they're all
interchangeable it's like the [ __ ]
it's like the titles were made by a
[ __ ] computer
you know what i mean well they probably
have a template they have the steven
seagal movie template like a template
like you know
and they and they even have you know for
vengeance right so like
for [ __ ] i was going to say you know
those like little poet magnets that they
have like magnets like little words on
them and you can like mix them up and
make poems and stuff so i feel like they
have that
but for steven seagal titles there's
there's been some like steven seagal
movies that have come up for free on
youtube me and jenny be sitting in bed
and
let's see what this is jenny would be
like oh no no no
no no do we have to it'll be like some
[ __ ] from 98 and then i'll watch it for
like 2002
or something and man now i'm going to
read by
they're not even they're not even bad
they're just boring
that's what i mean that's the worst of
the worst if they were
bad like entertainingly bad i'd be all
about
i love that [ __ ] yeah i love that the
problem with a newer
[ __ ] steven seagal movie is that that
[ __ ] isn't in it
he's not in it he's got a double that's
the only thing that's funny is like
spotting how many times they use the
body double the body double for him
doing like regular
just like walking walking down the
stairs walking up the stairs
walking up the stairs they got a damn
body double and go man that's not segal
you know i'm always and here what's
funny is that like he's [ __ ] 20 or 30
years younger than everybody else in the
movie
and he's supposed to be some kind of
[ __ ] mercenary or active duty special
forces guys but he's like
80 pounds overweight he's 30 years old
like in the universe of the movie maybe
everyone else is just like kind of
humoring him like like
you do with grandpa at thanksgiving it's
like whatever aliens do run the
government i know
and it's like you just like because you
don't want to like listen talk anymore
yeah
and he's doing that through the whole
[ __ ] movie and they're just doing a
close-ups of his
face because they don't want you to see
what he looks like because that
[ __ ] turned into job by the hut
he's a little rotund yeah i mean you
know i'm not judging i'm not body
shaming i'm just saying that it's like
for somebody that wants to come across
as like i'm an action star
yeah that's nice and honestly even back
and we i think we mentioned this before
even back in like some movies that were
made like in the
early 2000s like they clearly did not
give
a single [ __ ] if you notice that that
was a body double or not because they
will show the body double
which is like supposed to be steven
seagal they'll share the dude's face and
it's clearly not him
yeah it's clearly not him and they're
just kind of like whatever yeah they
don't even care
yeah they don't even care but seagal has
his own die-hard fans i guess
there are dudes that just did people
really like him like
because the dude from cinemassacre he
like he's like i like him ironically
just because i think he's like a
hilarious like he's just a
there must be enough of those to
actually i could see that live off
of in terms of a career it's
entertaining to an extent but like i
said a lot of his movies if they were
worse i would be more into it yeah
that's what i'm thinking
they need to be worse they're just
boring right they're boring and and
cgi gunshots and just [ __ ] you know
depending on what particular one but any
of the newer ones
the problem with them is that they're
not bad they're not bad enough
they're just boring exactly which that's
the worst if you're gonna make a bad
movie make it
real make it really bad yeah you know
that way you could just enjoy it
lean into it it's fun then but the four
that i mentioned
you know i'm giving [ __ ] results i'm
giving [ __ ] not results for you
recommendations what's that
recommendation giving recommendations
uh yeah she knows what i'm thinking i
know i know because in there going
she's gonna watch under siege under
siege is the best steven segal movement
it's okay
it's kind of like a lower budget die
hard it's
die hard on a battleship it has tommy
lee jones
but not nearly as good as dying no not
as good as bit diehard but
it's in that same vein sure and uh it's
got the girl from [ __ ] baywatch or
big old [ __ ] titties and
it's [ __ ] corny you you will see it
it's fun and it's corny under siege two
wasn't that bad
i like to understand did i see that it's
the same thing die hard on a train
instead of on a boat it's on a train
it's not as good as darha hard work but
it was
it was entertaining i probably did but i
don't remember
how was it hard to kill was a good one
you can't even think of like the names
kelly lebrock with them [ __ ] dick
sucking lips [ __ ] running around
i like hearing weird science yeah yeah
and then uh
probably out for justice were they
married at some point
they were married yeah i don't know how
he pulled that [ __ ] off he must have
lied his way through that how long did
that last
cocaine must have been involved cocaine
hadn't been involved
she must have been going through a bad
patch in her life i'm just hollywood
it's hollywood it's a scene
she's like oh he'll do for me yeah he'll
like yeah i'll leap frog off of this one
and [ __ ] maybe i can find something
better in a year
[Laughter]
when everyone was [ __ ] optimistic and
you have a [ __ ] bright future
i'm such a [ __ ] that's not what i'm just
saying it's like that's kind of like
you know yeah that's probably what they
were thinking it's like well
he's kind of famous he's kind of well
back then he was okay looking
daniel said that [ __ ] carl weathers
was in close encounters he was was he
i don't remember that well i haven't
seen close encounters wait what will
closing count like are we talking about
like the close encounter yeah i think he
is
i think he is was he yeah look that [ __ ]
up
imdb that [ __ ] right now hold on drugs
are a hell of a drug
drugs are a hell of a drug i said that
[Laughter]
plus encounters now i'm curious
now i'm very curious
yeah kelly the brock was married to
seagal from 1987 to 1996.
damn holy crap kelly
girl girl we need to talk
[Laughter]
what was that about yes carl weathers
was
in oh i don't doubt it i'm just saying i
don't have a military policeman
oh okay so he was kind of like an extra
he was not like a main role yeah
that's pretty badass though
it's just kind of like back in the old
days like [ __ ] clint eastwood was in
one of those like horrible 50s movies
with
with [ __ ] john agar yeah like working
in a monkey lab
and he was he had like one line or some
[ __ ] like that what the [ __ ] was that
movie
it wasn't mole people i can't remember
now it was one it was one that was on
the mystery design theater that's how i
know and i was like hey that's clint
eastwood
okay it's probably about time we can go
ahead and shut it down you sure
yeah you sure if you guys like the show
go ahead and [ __ ] like the show hit
that [ __ ] thumbs up button
like share and subscribe we will see you
guys
i think tomorrow right yeah tomorrow
we're going to talk about christmas
chronicles to you
yeah we've got to do christmas
chronicles too tomorrow because we watch
that if you haven't seen christmas
chronicles 2 go ahead and check that out
yeah i will for some reason i thought
that they weren't dropping it on netflix
until
the day after thanksgiving but they
actually put it on there the day before
thanksgiving because i was looking on
netflix just for what like before thing
like wednesday night i was saying like
hey what the [ __ ] that doing there
let's watch it
we'll get ourselves like all in a
holiday mood and whatnot what's [ __ ] man
our christmas tree is already up
yeah so you know all right
all right can't forget well he's our
leaving already i'm leaving yeah cause
you'll drag that [ __ ] out oh you'll drag
that [ __ ] out for hours i'm just saying
i'm
like really proud of myself because i'm
kind of like still coherent
and i covered the whole entire case so
it's not going to be a case where i wake
up in the middle and i'd be like oh [ __ ]
that i like [ __ ]
not finish i did i got all the way to
the end of my notes
yeah and i feel like i stayed on topic
most of the time
so i'm super proud of myself but yeah so
as always thank you guys for dropping by
remember like share subscribe on all
your social media if you
like the show would like to support the
show that would be much appreciated go
to patreon page patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog 13 o'clockpodcast.wordpress.com
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a paypal account if you'd like
to give a one-time donation
anything is much appreciated and is used
to
upgrade equipment things like that for
the show
so we will be back tomorrow talking
about christmas chronicles 2 with
chrysalis santa claus
on our matinee show so we'll see you
guys tomorrow
and thank you for dropping by as always
bye
could you stand